alors je vous invite à vous installer de
telle sorte que nous puissions
démarrer donc mais chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs à l'occasion de la
Journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la violence à l'égard
des femmes qui a lieu tout les ans le 25
novembre la délégation au droits des
femmes du Sénat a décidé d'organiser un
colloque consacré à un état des lieux du
droit et de l'accès à l'avortement dans
le monde parce que c'est pas toujours la
même chose nous considérons en effet que
le recul dans de nombreux pays des
droits sexuels et reproductifs au
premier rang desquels le droit à
l'avortement constitue une violence
faite aux femmes à l'échelle mondiale
partout où l'avortement est interdit par
la loi ou difficile voire impossible
d'accès dans des conditions sanitaires
fiables les femmes qui souhaitent y
recourir se tournent inévitablement vers
des pratiques clandestines qui mettent
leur vie en danger même lorsque
l'avortement est autorisé les femmes
sont parfois confrontées à des
professionnels de santé qui refusent de
le pratiquer ainsi l'organisation
mondiale de la santé l'OMS estime que 25
millions d'avortements non sécurisés
sont pratiqués chaque année dans le
monde donnant lieu à 39000 décès le
contexte international actuel n'est pas
de nature à nous rassurer sur plusieurs
continents l'accès à l'avortement n'est
autorisé que dans des conditions très
limitatives c'est le cas notamment aux
États-Unis dans de nombreux pays
d'Amérique latine d'Afrique d'Asie ou ou
d'Asie du Sud aux États-Unis Unis la
révocation en juin 2022 par la Cour
suprême de la jurisprudence r versus
suade de 73 qui consacrait au niveau
fédéral le droit à l'avortement pour les
femmes américaines dans tous les états
du pays a été un énorme coup dur porté à
l'encontre du droit des femmes à
disposer librement de leur corps tout
récemment en Argentine la victoire de
raviierre My à l'élection présidentielle
dimanche 19 novembre fait craindre un
véritable retour en arri hier avec la
promesse par le président élu de
l'organisation d'un référendum sur la
loi légalisant l'IVG adopté en 2020 et
je compléterai puisque le continent
européen n'est pas épargné par ses
reculs puisque plusieurs pays de
l'Europe je pense bien sûr à la Pologne
et à la Hongrie mais depuis ce matin
également à la aux Pays-Bas ont adopté
des législations drastiquement
restrictives en matière d'accès à l'IVG
même dans des pays rép les plus
progressistes les droits sexuels et
reproductifs des femmes restent fragiles
comme en Italie voire en Suède où la
participation de l'extrême droite à la
coalition gouvernementale pourrait
reouvrir le débat sur la réduction du
délai légal de
l'IVG une vigilance de tous les instants
est donc indispensable ce colloque
s'annonce passionnant et je remercie
vivement tous les participants qui sont
parmi nous ce matin nous avons décidé
d'ouvrir notre réunion à l'ensemble de
nos collègues sénatrices et sénateurs
afin de faire rayonner nos travaux
au-delà de la seule délégation aux
droits des femmes malheureusement il
faut le dire nous sommes aussi la
semaine du projet de loi de financeces
et du Salon des Maires et donc pour les
sénateurs le Salon des Maires c'est
quand même relativement important et
donc on a une sévère concurrence pour
autant mais je vous le dirai après donc
je suis heureuse que nous puissions
parler paisiblement de ces sujets au
Sénat surtout dans la perspective de la
réforme constitutionnel annoncé par le
président de la République qui prévoit
l'inscription dans notre constitution de
la garantie de la liberté des femmes de
recourir à l'IVG je rappelle à toutes
fins utiles que notre colloque est filmé
et diffusé en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et les réseaux sociaux
il sera également disponible par la
suite en vidéo à la demande et comme je
l'ai expliqué à certaines intervenantes
c'est vraiment ce sur quoi nous parons
pour pouvoir diffuser votre parole
j'invite main maintenant nos premiers
intervenants à me rejoindre sur
l'estrade notre collègue Sylvie Valente
Leir introduira et animera notre
première table ronde qui permettra de
dresser un panorama mondial des
législations en matière d'avortement et
des dernières évolutions en la
matière tu viens te mettre à mes côtés
Sylvie
ici et donc à ses côtés voilà c'est ce
que j'étais en train de regarder pour
appeler donc effectivement Azal at et
Anne
Légier et vraiment merci euh à tous les
intervenants de venir je pensais que ce
panorama global était intéressant avant
qu'on ait nos discussions sur notre
situation purement française à
toi merci madame la Présidente pour
cette
introduction notre première séquence a
pour but de dresser un panorama des
différentes législations sur l'IVG
applicable dans le monde au cours des 25
dernières années si plus de 50 pays ont
modifié leur législation par pour
faciliter l'accès des femmes à
l'avortement force est de constater que
dans de nombreuses régions du monde ce
droit est encore restreint fragile voire
inexistant en 2023 l'avortement est
autorisé sur dememande sans restriction
dans le respect d'un certains délai dans
75 pays et pour des raisons
socio-économiques dans 13 autres il est
strictement interdit dans 24 pays
autorisés seulement pour sauver la vie
de la mer dans 41 pays et seulement pour
raison de santé dans 49
pays selon le Center for reproductive 41
% des femmes en âge de procréé dans le
monde vivent dans des pays où la
législation sur l'avortement est
restrictive soit près de 700 millions de
femmes toutes les régions du monde sont
concernées par l'existence de
législation restrictive en matière de
droit à l'IVG et par l'absence de réelle
sécurisation juridique de ce droit aux
États-Unis par exemple le revirement de
jurisprudence de la Cour suprême en juin
2 2022 que citit notre présidente
Dominique Verrien a entraîné l'adoption
de lois très restrictive voire
prohibitive pour les femmes dans
plusieurs États américains ainsi
l'Alabama et le Missouri ont voté une
interdiction totale de l'avortement même
en cas d'inceste de viol ou de danger
pour la vie de la femme enceinte
certains États ont également fait
adopter des législations criminalisant
toute interruption de grossesse dès que
le pou du fettus est détectable à
contrario d'autres États tels que la
Californie ont tenu à renforcer ce droit
plus récemment l'état de l'oho a
approuvé par référendum mardi 7 novembre
2023 l'inscription du droit à
l'avortement dans sa
constitution en Amérique latine 97 % des
femmes en âge de procréé vivent dans un
état dont la législation restreint l' à
l'avortement d'après la Fédération
internationale pour les droits humains
on l'a vu l'avancée historique en
décembre 2020 qu constitué la
dépénalisation de l'avortement en
Argentine est aujourd'hui menacé avec
l'élection du nouveau président argentin
dimanche dernier l'Afrique est un des
continents où les lois sont les plus
restrictives en matière de droit à l'g
et certains États africains ont adopté
des lois criminalisant le recours à l'av
chaque année 6,2 millions d'avortements
à risque sont ainsi pratiqués en Afrique
subsaharienne causant au moins 15000
décès même en Europe ce droit reste
menacé et s'applique de façon très
hétérogène pour évoquer ensemble cette
disparité de législation dans le monde
je souhaite la bienvenue aux deux
participantes à cette première table
ronde madame Azal ataille
docteur en sciences politiques
chercheuse au laboratoire d'évaluation
interdisciplinaire des politiques
publiques à sciencesp Paris et
spécialiste de droit comparés en matière
d'accès à l'avortement Madame Anne
Légier docteur en civilisation
américaine maîtresse de conférence à
l'Université Paris Cité spécialiste de
l'histoire de l'avortement et de la
contraception aux États-Unis donc je
laisse sans plus tarder la parole à
Azal
merci euh bonjour et merci pour cette
introduction euh j'ai le plaisir de vous
adresser aujourd'hui pour faire un
panorama des lois et des politiques
publiques sur l'aportement dans le monde
qui est évidemment un Vasse sujet euh
mais je vais quand même essayer de de
faire un de de le faire autour de
quelques grands thèmes que qui démontent
en fait la réglementation exceptionnelle
de l'avorttement dans les lois et dans
les politiques publiques et des
conséquences problématiques qui en
découlent euh pour commencer j'aimerais
bien préciser pourquoi je parle des lois
et des politiques publiques en même
temps même s'ils sont pas vraiment
conçus par des mêmes groupes de
personnes ou ne traite pas forcément les
mêmes sujets euh mais en fait c'est
qu'it du terrain l'accès à la santé en
général et des l'accès à des soins de
santé stigmatisés comme l'avortement
dépendent de plusieurs facteurs qui peut
relever du droit et des lois mais aussi
des politiques publiques et de système
de santé on constate que même dans les
pays où l'avortement lég il existe des
problèmes d'accès et les femmes
continuent à se heurter à des obstacles
qui les empêchent d'accéder à
l'avortement il est donc important de
d'être consciente que la loi seule ne
garantit pas l'accès à l'avortement et
on doit penser à l'avortement de manière
holistique comme un écosystème aux
différentes dimensions qui peut révéler
des droits et des lois mais aussi des
politiques publiques et systèmes de
santé et c'est important de d'être
consciente aussi que ces dimensions ne
sont pas isolées non plus mais contraire
en fait elle se croise euh assez souvent
par exemple on sait que la
criminalisation de l'abortement
contribue à la stigmatisation de
l'avortement de sorte que la manière
dont on parle de l'avartement dans nos
lois a un impact en fait sur le terrain
et sur l'accès à l'avortement je
voudrais développer sur la
criminalisation de l'avortement parce
qu'il montre assez de manière assez
simple et directe le traitement
exceptionnel de l'avortement dans la loi
et et en fait l'avortement constitue un
de RAR soin de santé qui qui est inclu
dans les codes pénales à travers le
monde dans plusieurs pays et il est
souvent associé à des sanctions pénales
ainsi que sanction administrative en
fait même dans les pays où l'avortement
est légal l'avortement reste toujours
inscrit dans le code pénal et c'est par
exemple le cas en Allemagne et en
Belgique entre autres et dans ce
contexte la légalisation de l'avortement
est en fait défini de manière
exceptionnelle à sa criminalisation et
on peut penser que c'est bon B c'est pas
ça pose pas un problème parce que c'est
mieux que rien au moins il y a des
exceptions qui permettent permettre à
l'avortement mais quand même C
traitement de de l'ortement dans les
lois reste problématique parce que d'un
point de vue analytique et aussi
juridique parce que c loi confirme
toujours la criminalité générale de
l'avartement ceci est également en
contradiction avec les recommandations
de l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
qui recommande la dépanalisation
complète de l'avortement qui consist et
je cite la dépénalisation consiste à
retirer l'avortement de la législation
pénale à ne pas appliquer d'autres
infractions pénale à l'avortement et à
s'assurer qu'il n'existe aucune sanction
pénale autour de l'avortement pour tous
les acteurs concernés aujourd'hui donc
la dépénalisation complète de l'ortement
est le cas seulement dans un seul pays
du monde et c'est le cas de Canada où
l'avortement a été complètement
décriminalisé il y a plus de 30 ans ai
la Criminal anisation de l'avortement
est problématique et réflète le
traitement exceptionnel de l'avortement
dans les lois a également des
conséquences sur l'accès à l'avortement
sur le terrain deuxème thème ou mes
connaissances si vous voulez que
j'aimerais bien aborder concerne la
légalisation de l'avortement ou le droit
à l'avortement donc tout d'abord c'est
important de dire qu'il ne faut pas en
fait confondre la légalisation de
l'avortement avec la décriminalisation
de l'avortement bien qu'on parle de ces
deux processus de manière
interchangeable en fait ça constitue
deux processus différentes par exemple
on a on a évoqué qu'il y a récemment une
vague verte de décriminalisation de
l'avortement en Amérique latine ce qui
constitue évidemment une une grande
évolution vu les restrictions
précédentes mais si la dépénalisation de
l'avartement en Argentine a conduit à la
légalisation de l'avartement avec la
promulgation d'une loi spécifique qui
protège ce droit cela n'est pas encore
le cas au Mexique où l'avartement a été
décriminalisé et plus plusieurs
exceptions ont été définis dans les les
codes pénaux des États respectifs mais
il n'existe toujours pas une loi qui
protège et garantir l'accès à
l'avortement donc cela me mène à la
question de droit à l'avortement et que
je voudrais aborder qui nous concerne
ici au Sénat je pense surtout dans le
cadre de projet de loi sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'avortement
et c'est la question de savoir si
l'avortement est un droit et quand cet
unendroit et s'il y a des pays qui connu
en fait qui connaissent l'avortement
comme unendroit donc malgré notre
tendance à faire référence au droit à
l'avortement quand on parle de
l'avortement dans les lois l'avortement
en fait est rarement reconnu comme un
droit en soi dans le droit international
on parle souvent de principes des droits
humaines à respecter autour de soin liés
à l'avortement mais on ne connaît pas
l'avortement pour l'instant et en soit
comme un droit pourtant quelques pays
dans le monde considèent et trait
l'avortement comme endroit et il s'agit
souvent des pays soit post-soviétiqu
comme l'Arménie azerbaïjan Kazakistan
turkmistan et la Russie ainsi que des
pays où l'avortement a été récemment
légalisé comme l'Argentine et le Népal
et finalement aussi le Vietnam et
l'Islande donc en Arménie Kazakistan
Turkménistan et en Islande les lois font
référence soit au droit à l'interruption
de grossesse ou droit à l'interruption
artificielle de grossesse la loi au
Vietnam stipule que les femmes ont le
droit à l'avortement et au Népal la loi
affirme que les femmes ont le droit à
l'avortement sécurisé donc ce dernier
donc le cas de Népal en fait fait
référence à quelque chose bien attesté
dans la recherche s l'avortement c'est à
savoir que là où l'avortement est
interdit l'interdiction de l'avortement
n'empêche pas les avortements de se
produire mais les rendent plutôt
dangereux et clandestin donc en fait ce
qui reste au loi et aux politiques
publiqu si vous voulez c'est de décider
si les avortements seront pratiqués de
manière sécurisée et non et c'est cette
langage qu'on observe dans les loi au
Népal donc la deuxième chose que je
voulais souligner est le fait que que
même si l'avortementond est rarement
reconnu comme un droit en soi il y a
quelques pays qui le font et on peut
aussi faire ce choix en France ici donc
mon trème point consiste à aborder
l'avortement de manière holistique en
tant que écosystème comme j'ai suggéré
précédemment à la fois dans les lois
mais aussi au-delà peut-être des lois
dans les politiques publiques dans le
système de santé donc j'ai déjà
mentionné à plusieurs reprises et
c'était équé aussi dans l'introduction
que l'accès à l'avortement en fait
constitue une démension supplémentaire
si vous voulez à la légalisation de
l'avortement donc c'est pas la même
chose et la légalisation de l'avortement
ne garantit pas toujours l'accès à
l'avortement mais c'est pas pour dire
que on ne peut pas faire des lois qui
facilitent l'accès à l'avortement là où
cela est nécessaire est demandé donc un
aspect critique qui entre en jeu
peut-être quand on parle de l'accès à
l'avortement c'est le choix et c'est la
question si nos lois sur l'avortement
dont vraiment le choix au femme cette
question et cette thème le choix est
évidemment central au sein de mou
féministe et qui revindique le droit à
l'avortement et c'était l'une des
raisons pour lesquelle la
criminalisation de l'avortement a été
problématisée parce qu'elle ne donne pas
le choix aux femmes si elles souhaitent
continuer ou pas leur grossesse et et si
dans le pays où l'avortement reste
criminalisé ou ça reste limité c'est
l'État qui qui en décide en fait mais
aussi dans certains pays où l'avortement
est dépénalisé on n toujours pas
vraiment donné le choix aux femmes mais
aux médecin c'est une nuance importante
parce qu'on peut avoir des situations où
les demandes des femmes sont en conflit
avec cellu des médecins et prendre le
part de médecin dans ce contexte nous
empêche de répondre à la demande des
femmes qui passent par cette expérience
d'une grossesse non désirée et qui a
besoin de l'avortement et c'est le cas
en Italie par exemple euh donc c'est
important que les lois et les politiques
publiques sous l'avortement se
concentrent sous les femmes et les
personnes centes qui vivent l'expérience
d'une Gresse non désirée qui cherchent
qui se font avorter et nos système de
soin de santé doit être centré sur les
patient sous leurs préférences et leurs
besoins c'est aussi important parce que
nous sommes confrontés souvent à une
opposition qui présente l'avortement
comme un conflit d'intérêt mais il faut
reconnaître que toutes les parties
concernées n'ont pas le même intérêt
dans dans l'avortement et ce sont celles
qui ont besoin de l'avortement qui doit
être prioritaire donc c'est pour dire
que les lois et politiques et les
politiques publiques sur l'avortement
doivent être centré sur les femmes et
les HES deidcentes leurs besoins et
leurs préférences alors pour revenir à
ma question et pour finir avec ça
comment peut-on faire des lois et des
politiques publiques qui facilitent
l'accès à
l'avortement une formule pour y parvenir
comme je viens de le mentionner
peut-être se concentrer sur les
expériences les besoins et les
préférences des femmes et des personnes
en santé une autre formule qui peut
alimenter nos réflexion et nos
politiques c'est de suivre la science et
les recommandations internationales
notamment celles de l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé et sur ce point je
dois noter que la France est en retard
par rapport à certaines recommandations
de l'OMS il existe encore nombreuses
restrictions arbitraires à l'avortement
dans nos lois et nos politiques
publiques le cours délai pendant lequel
on autorise l'avortement et le délai
encore plus court pendant lequel on
autorise l'avortement médicamenteux ne
sont que quelques exemples qui sont pas
alignés avec les recommandations de
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
encore une formule ou plutôt une
question qui peut nous guider dans nos
réflexions et dans nos politiques c'est
la question de savoir comment on peut
garantir l'accès à l'avortement même aux
femmes et personnes les plus vulnérables
et marginalisées à celles qui ont des
ressources limitées celles qui sont
peut-être jeunes qui connaissent pas
forcément les lois et les politiques
publi sur cette question donc comment on
peut garantir l'accès à l'avortement
pour toutes et tous qui l'ont besoin de
manière digne et respectueux on doit
réfléchir via ce prisme parce que
l'avortement est un soin de santé
essentiel comme proclamé par l'OMS c'est
une question de justice social comme
démontré par le recherche et aussi comme
on a évoqué ça reste un droit fragile et
c'est un nous de le de l'avancer donc je
vais concl mes mot ici et bien sûr je
vais être contente de de répondre à vos
questions
merci merci AZ la taille pour cette
présentation je laisse maintenant la
parole à Anne
Légier pardon donc madame la Présidente
Mesdames les vice-présidentes mesdames
et messieurs les membres de la
délégation mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs merci de m'avoir
invité à l'occasion de cette journée
consacrée à l'accès à l'avortement dans
le monde j'y ai été invité pour parler
de la situation actuelle aux États-Unis
après le récent revirement de
jurisprudence rendu par la Cour suprême
en 2022 alors étant donné le temps
imparti je ferai un bref rappel du cadre
juridique dans lequel s'inscrit l'arrêt
Dobs versus Jackson Women's Health
Organization avant d'endresser les
conséquences les plus notable à l'aide
de quelques
exemples alors pour bien comprendre
comment se pose le problème aux
États-Unis il faut avoir à l'esprit que
la législation sur l'avortement dépend
des États fédérés et non de l'État
fédéral et le schéma classique de
nombreuses questions juridiques est
alors de savoir si telle loi d'un État
est conforme au principe constitutionnel
de la Fédération l'arrêt d'obs qui a mis
fin à 49 ans de protection
constitutionnelle du droit à
l'avortement a pour origine un procès
intenté dans le Mississippi et dont
l'objet était de déterminer si une loi
interdisant les interruptions de
grossesse avant le seuil de viabilité
était conforme à la Constitution et
l'affaire s'inscrivait dans une
stratégie relativement nouvelle de la
part des mouvements anti-avortement de
proposer des lois clairement contraires
à la jurisprudence en vigueur afin de
remettre en cause le droit à
l'avortement alors en 2018 sous
l'impulsion des lobbyes anti-avortement
l'État du Mississippi avait adopté une
loi qui interdisait la plupart des
interruptions de grossesse dès la 15e
semaine d'aménoré ce qui était
anticonstitutionnel car contraire aux
arrêts RW versus W 273 et plan
Parenthood VKC de 1992 contre toute
attente la Cour ne se contenta pas de
modifier le cadre constitutionnel mais
opta pour un renversement total de
jurisprudence un fait qui est très rare
aux
États-Unis où la continuité du droit est
un principe
essentiel mettant en avant une approche
originaliste de la Constitution la Cour
a statué que l'avortement ne pouvait
être un droit protégé donc le cadre
établi par r versus weight qui
n'autorisait pas les États à interdire
l'avortement avant le seil de viabilité
et limiter leur capacité à restreindre
son accès tout au long de la grossesse a
donc aujourd'hui totalement
disparu
alors la question de l'avortement a par
conséquent été renvoyé aux seuls États
fédérés qui sont maintenant libre de le
protéger de l'interdire et de le
réglementer à leur
guise alors dans les grandes lignes
quelle est la situation à l'échelle
nationale d'abord l'avortement est
désormais interdit dans 14 États l'AV se
États ont établi une limite
gestationnale gestationnelle pardon qui
va de 4 semaines de gros en Géorgie ou
en Caroline du Sud à 16 semaines de
grossesse dans l'UTA
ensuite dans 5 états la situation est
actuellement incertaine en majorité
parce que des lois adoptées ont été
suspendues temporairement par un juge et
enfin en réaction à l'arrêt d'obs 20
États plus le district de Colombie
c'est-à-dire Washington DC ont établi de
nouvelles protections législatives ou
constitutionnelles pour le droit à
l'avorte
alors pour avoir une meilleure idée de
la situation
actuelle je vous propose de regarder
deux cartes alors sur cette première
carte qui est extraite du du New York
Times on voit un panorama des lois
restrictives qui vont de l'interdiction
totale en rouge foncé jusqu'à des
limites
gestationnelles donc on a évoqué l'état
de luta Caroline du Sud et cetera alors
ce qu'on voit déjà sur cette première
carte mais qu'on verra encore mieux sur
la seconde c'est qu'on a de très grandes
disparité géographique euh avec les
états protecteurs donc le le code
couleur est relativement transparent
euh donc les état protecteur qui se
situe en grande majorité sur les deux
côtes avec un un à quelques exceptions
près un grand désert médical au centre
et au sud du pays euh donc on constate
de très grandes disparités
géographiques et euh je voudrais euh
vous parler un petit peu de de certains
é état protecteur que qui qui se situe
donc comme on le voit sur la carte
essentiellement sur les les deux côes
les deux côtes mais comme on le voit
également sur la carte on a un état qui
est au centre hein l'état de l'Ilinois
où se trouve la ville de de Chicago que
vous connaissez
euh donc cette état occupe une position
centrale et son gouverneur a professé la
volonté d'en faire un état refuge qui
pourrait accueillir les personnes
provenant d'État voisin et même d'états
plus lointains euh dans cet état les
assurances privées et publi sont tenus
de prendre en charge l'avortement il n'y
a pas de délai dit de réflexion imposé
il n'y a pas d'obligation pour une
mineur d'informer ses parents et les
infirmières spécialisé ou les médecins
assistants sont autorisés à pratiquer
des av des
avortements l'état protège également le
personnel médical les associations et
les patientes contre les poursuites
judiciaires qui seraient engagé dans un
autre pays ou un état ayant une
législation différente en revanche dans
cet état la avortement n'est en principe
pas autorisé après le seuil de viabilité
et j'aimerais euh vous vous parler d'un
autre exemple l'exemple de l'État du
Colorado où la situation est un peu
différente he l'État du Colorado occupe
aussi une place centrale parce qu'il
fait depuis longtemps partie des États
qui ne disposent pas de limit
gestationnelles et donc depuis de
nombreuses années il accueille des
personnes en situation de dépassement de
délais qui proviennent de tout le pays
mais également de l'étranger notamment
de
France alors parmi les États ayant
adopté des législations plus
restrictives euh je vais en évoquer deux
le Texas et la
geéorgie alors il faut savoir qu'en 2020
près de 60000 personnes ont ont avorté
dans l'État du Texas aujourd'hui
l'interdiction est totale ce qui laisse
peu d'alternative aux personnes
souhaitant interrompre une grossesse
voyager hors de l'État ce qui n'est pas
toujours possible notamment en raison du
coup ou bien la maternité forcée avec
les conséquences que l'on peut imaginer
au niveau psychologique social
économique mais aussi tout simplement
médical et là j'aimerais attirer votre
attention sur le fait que lorsqu'on
parle de l'avortement aux États-Unis on
parle des interruptions de grossesse en
général et pas seulement des IVG
euh la loi au Texas est en effet
tellement restrictive qu'elle met en
danger la santé des personnes en âge de
procréer de manière globale euh les
médecins ne se sentent pas libres de
pratiquer certaines interventions qu'il
juge pourtant médicalement nécessairire
en cas de complications qui sont associé
à la grossesse plusieurs femmes dans cet
état ont récemment porté plainte en
disant que que la législation met leur
vie en danger en interdisant aux
médecins d'interrompre toute grossesse
même une grossesse qui ne serait pas
viable alors l'une d'entre elle à titre
d'exemple faisait une fausse couche et
elle n'a pas pu obtenir un curtage avant
de développer une septicémie hein donc
on voit les les les conséquences
drastiques et tout à l'heure on parlait
de grossesse non désirées mais ici il
s'agit de grossesses qui sont désirées
alors euh en Géorgie la situation est un
peu différente hein ça n'est pas une
interdiction totale mais l'avortement
est interdit des 6 semaines d'aménorer
quand beaucoup de femmes ne savent pas
encore qu'elles sont enceintes de
surcroix l'état interdit l'utilisation
de fonds publics locaux exige que les
parents d'une mineur consentent à
l'intervention ou reçoivent notification
imposent un délai dit de réflexion de 24
heures et ne permet pas aux
professionnels de santé qui ne sont pas
médecins de pratiquer un
avortement alors dans sa décision la
Cour avait affirmé le fait que le fait
de renvoyer le droit à l'avortement aux
États fédérés permettrait de résoudre un
certain nombre de questions qui qui
étaient resté en suspens dans les 50
dernières années en réalité il n'en est
rien Laar redobs a créé une situation ch
tique complexe car elle soulève de
nombreuses questions de souveraineté
alors des questions de souveraineté
entre État fédéré et État fédéral entre
état fédérés eux-mêmes entre pouvoir
exécutif et pouvoir législatif entre
lois tombé en désuétudes et pratique
courante et même entre domaines
d'application du droit euh liberté
d'expression liberté de circulation et
même liberté d'entreprendre euh alors à
titre d'exemple on peut mentionner euh
la question de l'accès légal à
l'avortement médicamenteux qui nécessite
comme vous le savez sans doute d'avoir
recours à deux médicaments la mifé
priston et le misoprostol or plusieurs
organisations anti-avortement ont
intenté des actions en justice pour
contester la validité la validité de la
mise sur le marché en 2000 de l'AMIF
priston par l'autorité du médicament
américaine la FDA et les conséquences
potentielles de cette démarche sont
nombreuses et difficile à déterminer à
l'heure actuelle euh alors ce qui est
beaucoup plus facile à déterminer c'est
le fait que l'accès à l'avortement dont
parlait ma collègue
euh a été grandement impacté par cette
cet arrêt de la Cour suprême alors tout
d'abord il faut quand même préciser que
les difficultés d'accès existait déjà
avant l'arrêt récent de la Cour suprême
l'arrêt de 92 KC avait considérablement
modifier le cadre constitutionnel en
accordant beaucoup plus de droit aux
États fédérés pour mettre en place des
restriction qui s'appliquaient aux
patientes ou euh au aux praticiens alors
pour les patientes je peux en citer un
l'obligation de faire une échographie
par exemple avant d'obtenir un
avortement ou des contraintes qui
s'appliquaient aux praticiens euh
beaucoup de contraintes administratives
surtout ces dernières années des
contraintes administratives et
matérielles qui ont amené un assez grand
nombre de cliniques à devoir fermer car
ell n'arrivait pas à répondre à ces ces
contraintes donc l'accès à l'avortement
était déjà difficile avant l'arrêt d' s
dans de nombreux États conservateurs
néanmoins les problématiques d'accès se
sont considérablement
euh aggravé après l'arr d'obs et touche
davantage les plus vulnérables celles
qui n'ont pas les moyens économiques
sociaux familiaux ou légaux de voyager
et je pense en particulier aux plus
démunis aux maères de famille isolé aux
mineurs aux personnes sans papier aux
femmes victimes de violence domestique
comme avant l'arrêt R versus W dans les
États les plus restrictif les personnes
les plus affectées sont celles qui n'ont
pas les ressources nécessaires pour
contourner les
interdictions merci pour votre attention
et c'est avec plaisir que je répondrai à
vos
questions un grand merci pour cette
intervention Anne Légier sur la
situation aux États-Unis que je
qualifierai d'étatdésunis en en matière
donc de protection pour la femme de la
de l'avortement
euh merci à toutes les deux je vous
propose maintenant de de passer aux
questions si vous souhaitez si vous avez
des des des questions sur ces sujets
nous
avons c'est toujours dur de commencer
donc je vais poser la première question
euh on
parlait vous parliez du Mexique alors ça
c'est un lien les États-Unis et et le
Mexique pour le coup parce que j'avais
cru comprendre que au Mexique le droit
existait mais l'accès était pas si
simple que ça or j'ai aussi entendu que
bah au Texas si on voulait se faire
avorter le plus simple c'était quand
même de passer la frontière et d'aller
au Mexique donc ça pour moi les deux
informations j'ai l'impression qu'elles
se contredisent c'estàd qu'il y a accès
alors peut-être qu'en fait la vraie
réponse c'est il y a un accès mais quand
on a les moyens de le faire quoi des
moyens financiers ou et là ça vous
concerne toutes les deux donc une
question
commune juste sur le Mexique euh c'est
que je peux dire donc euh bon ça change
en fait parce que à Mexico City c'était
déjà légalisé donc il y a un accès et
beaucoup de femmes voyagaient vers le
Mexico City euh mais c'était pas
forcément le cas dans d'autres États
euh donc c'est ça qui a changé récemment
mais après avec la situation aux
États-Unis il y a pas mal des femmes qui
voyagent vers Mexique je pense que peut
leur répondre ça oui oui tout à fait euh
merci pour cette question madame la
Présidente donc il y a une longue
histoire en fait de voyage entre le
Mexique et les États-Unis avant rsus
Wade l'une des avocates qui a défendu
Jane RW dans dans l'affaire Sarah
Wellington a plus tard révélé dans sa
biographie qu'elle avait elle-même au
milieu des années 60 traverser la
frontière pour obtenir un avortement au
Mexique où c'était interdit à l'époque
et c'est justement ça permet de
souligner la différence entre
interdiction et pratique enfin la
différence entre loi et accès donc il y
a voilà euh actuellement effectivement
il y a un certain nombre de personnes
qui traversent la frontière pour obtenir
des soins d'ailleurs pas seulement
l'accès à l'avortement la contraception
mais aussi d'autres soins y compris
parfois
esthétique c'est quand même difficile
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord il faut
être en mesure de traverser la frontière
donc pour les personnes sans papier qui
sont nombreuses à la frontière ça ne
fonctionne pas et puis il y a des
questions de sécurité récemment quelques
américains ont été kidnappés certains
tués donc ça n'est pas évident mais en
tout cas pour ce qui est de la question
de la la pilule abortive beaucoup de de
gens traversent la frontière pour se
rendre dans des pharmacies au Mexique
donc voilà la la boucle
continue alors je donne la parole à Nick
billon puis ensuite Olivia Richard j'ai
vu d'autres mains se lever peut-être bon
déjà anque billon merci madame la
Présidente merci à vous mesdames chers
collègues pour cette présentation qui
nous vous faire entrer tout de suite
dans le vif du sujet je voudrais d'abord
dire que je suis profondément attachée à
ce droit fondamental et bien entendu
lorsqu'il y a eu des sujets au Sénat
portés dans l'hémicycle j'ai voté ces
propositions de loi avec enthousiasme et
conviction euh je voudrais peut-être
vous interroger par rapport à à au à la
contestation du droit de l'IVG qui qui
monte dans de nombreux pays est-ce que
vous pouvez dater Pr précisément
finalement on voit un phénomène de masse
quand même depuis plusieurs années daté
cette montée de la contestation du droit
à l'IVG et je voudrais vous poser la
question aussi de savoir si il y a des
études qui montrent que plus les les les
les les partis politiques extrémistes
montent plus ce droit àivg est contesté
je voudrais aussi savoir si on sait
qu'on se dans cette délégation madame
même la présidente qu'on travaille pour
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes pour pour l'égalité la parité
est-ce que dans les pays où par
exemple l'égalité salariale n'est pas un
sujet donc est-ce que les pays où les
femmes ont plus
facilement droit à l'égalité est-ce que
les femmes qui ont plus facilement droit
à l'égalité salariale est-ce que ce
droit est moins mis en moins contesté et
également
est-ce que les lorsque les femmes sont
plus nombreuses en politique OST à
responsabilité est-ce qu'il y a un lien
sur la contestation à la fois dans la
législation et puis une dernière
question je ne sais pas si vous pourrez
y répondre c'est sur les associations
lorsqu'il y a une contestation il y a
forcément des associations qui qui
portent cette contestation qui y
travaillent
donc comment sont-elles financées est-ce
que
comment table ronde suivant
pardon alors vous
garderez pardon excusez-moi donc moi
j'ai j'ai j'ai groupisé toutes mes
questions parce queil y a l'audition du
ministre Marc F derrière et donc je
serais peut-être amené à vous quitter
donc du coup j'ai j'ai mis une question
à notre collègue Laurence Rossignol qui
animera la table ronde suivante merci à
vous
mesdames
alors ma collègue sera plus à même de
répondre de manière globale hein juste
sur sur les États-Unis merci beaucoup
pour cette question
euh donc la la première partie qui était
sur les les parti extrémiste alors
évidemment l'exemple des États-Unis
c'est quand même assez marquant on voit
bien que la décision à l'arrêt BR versus
W c'est le résultat direct de l'élection
de de Donald Trump et de de ce le la la
un peu de manipulation politique un peu
de chance qui lui a permis de nommer
trois juges extrêmement conservateurs à
la Cour suprême euh sur la question de
de l'égalité on peut aussi souligner
qu'aux États-Unis il n'y a pas de
protection constitutionnelle sur
l'égalité et
que voilà le equal right amendment qui
est proposé très régulièrement depuis
des des
décennies et qui a priori ne semble pas
particulièrement controversé n'a pas pu
être adopté aux États-Unis donc sans
doute que le equ amendment pourrait
protéger et aurait pu permettre de de pr
un peu les effets de de cette de cet
arrêt alors il y aurait encore beaucoup
de choses à dire mais je je te laisse
parler de du cadre international h juste
sur cette question bon en fait le
comptecou ou le backlash comme on
qualifie contre l'égalité de je
l'égalité à FEM homme existait toujours
mais vous avez raison que il y a une
montée en fait on parle d'une montée de
ces mouvements et c'est qu'on observe
c'est surtout que tous ces mouvements
antichoix antigens sont très bien
connectés euh à à niveau national mais
aussi au niveau international ils sont
très présentes surtout dans les dans les
espaces de de l'ONU par exemple et et il
travaillent euh pour leur agenda euh et
mais ça existe toujours mais il y a une
monté et et si on regarde en fait
pourquoi on on observe cette cette
montée de de tout ce mement et bien sûr
ça ça allient avec le politique euh là
où euh et l'avortement ça ça entre en
jeu parce que c'est un de droit qui est
attaqué aux premières en fait où il y a
tous ces antichoix antigens l'avortement
et c'était le cas en Pologne par exemple
c'était vraiment le droit qui en était
attaqué au première euh mais en fait
juste aussi pour répondre aux questions
si on observe moins de de de menaces
contre à le droit avartement dans les
pays où il y a plus d'égalité donc je
vais répondre ça à deux à à peut-être
dans une manière un peu inverse pour
dire que il y a plus donc où
l'avortement est légalisé on observe que
la participation des femmes au March
marché de travail augmente donc on a on
a pu observer cet effet un peu dans le
recherche et on on a pu observer aussi
où l'égalité de Gen l'égalité de femme
homme est mise en question il y a des
attaques contre l'avortement mais je
pense que la table rond prochaine va
adresser plus plus en détail à votre
question Olivier
Richard je sais pas si j'arrive à
allumer le micro merci madame la
Présidente merci mesdames je rejoint
Annique billon pour ses ses
remerciements sur cet événement qui
permet de de parler d'un sujet qui est
qui est à mon sens fondamental je suis
sénatrice des Français établis hors de
France et donc des Françaises établis
hors de France et l'Assemblée des
Français l'étranger qui réunit des élus
français du monde entier a pu travailler
sur ces questions et mettre en lumière
des disparités du du droit auxquel les
gens n'ont pas nécessairement accès et
connaiss et lorsque des françaises
arrivent dans un pays où l'avortement
n'est pas
légal on se rend compte qu'il y a toute
une foule de conséquence sur dont on
éétait pas du tout informé par exemple
une femme qui fait une fausse couche et
qui se retrouve interrogée par la police
parce qu'elle va à l'hôpital pour un
suivi médical classique donc c'est des
conséquences qu'on ne mesure pas et je
salue le travail de Laurence etal chapui
qui est présidente du conseil consulaire
à Dublin et qui a beaucoup travaillé sur
ces questions euh première question
madame madame at vous avez commencé
votre propos en disant que la loi seule
ne garantit pas l'accès à
l'avortement tout en faisant cette
distinction entre la légalisation et
l'absence de mesures pénales
sanctionnant finalement quelles
conséquences pratiques ça a à partir du
moment où on peut accéder à l'avortement
même dans des conditions peut-être de
délai insuffisant ou mais quelles
conséquences concrètes ça peut avoir et
quelle diff différ concrète voyez-vous
dans la reconnaissance d'un droit à
l'avortement ou d'une
liberté des femmes à accéder à cet
avortement et Madame Légier j'aurais
également une
question aux États-Unis a-t-on observé
justement un une augmentation des
poursuites pénales des femmes dans les
États qui ont interdit cet avortement
est-ce que le système pénal s'est mis
également en œuvre outre les
impossibilités concrètes d'y accéder
merci
du coup la criminalisation de
l'avortement a a certainement un impact
sur le terrain sur l'accès à
l'avortement par exemple on sait bien
que en fait les médecins veul bien sûr
éviter souvent ils ont peut-être peur de
de de d'être d'être criminalisé donc
pour éviter ça et ils vont faire
peut-être une conception une
interruption beaucoup plus limitée de de
la loi qui qui est en vigueur euh donc
là on voit queil est pour éviter la
criminalisation il peut-être il décide
de ne pas pratiquer ou il il interprète
la loi d'une manière très restrictif
donc c'est un impact on sait très bien
qui existe et c'était bien àesté dans le
recherche et puis aussi le fait que en
fait l'avortement est dans le code pénal
et c'est pas le cas d'autes d'autres
soins de santé ça quand même contribue à
la stigmatisation général de
l'avortement donc ça reste problématique
en esprit mais aussi en pratique si vous
voulez euh donc je vais prendre ça comme
ça peut-être
oui merci beaucoup pour votre question
donc qui portait sur les les États-Unis
alors sur la question de l'augmentation
des poursuites judiciaires alors il y a
il y a quelques exemples mais qui sont
relativement marginaux et notamment il
me semble dans l'État de
l'Indiana mais ce qui est le plus
marquant c'est c'est c'est la peur qui a
été comment dire que déclenche cette
décision euh essentiellement euh dans le
corps médical c'est-à-dire que quand
qu'on a quand on a des médecins qui
hésitent à pratiquer des soins qui sont
pourtant des soins élémentaire hein a
une femme qui fait une fausse couche ou
ou une réduction enambillonnaire en cas
de de de grossesse multiple et cetera ça
a un effet très très important
euh sur la qualité des soins une autre
chose c'est que le risque qui plane même
si en effet il est relativement marginal
le risque qui plane fait que les femmes
sont sont plus hésitantes à se rendre
par exemple à l'hôpital quand elles font
une fausse couche hein donc on a un
impact qui est à la fois symbolique et
pratique je sais pas si si ça répond à
votre question merci et moi j'ai une
dernière question avant de passer à la à
la table ronde suivante à moins qu'il y
ait d'autres questions que je n'ai pas
vu j'ai une dernière question puisque
souvent on dit oui mais il faudrait
mieux développer la cont contraception
plutôt que d'avoir recours à l'IVG
est-ce que les États qui interdisent
l'IVG aujourd'hui aux États-Unis
n'essayent pas aussi d'interdire la
contraception ah oui totalement
totalement donc les on il y aurait
beaucoup à dire sur les les personnes
qui sont au manettees he qui qui les
lobes anti avortement sont généralement
menés par des gens qui sont
sont hostile à la contraception et qui
sont parfois même hostiles à la
procréation médicalement assistée
puisque si par exemple dans l'État du
Kentucky on dit que dans la loi de
l'État du Kentucky on dit que la la la
vie commence à la conception donc ça
veut dire que ça peut remettre en cause
voilà les les questions de de d'accès à
la procréation médicalement assistée
donc clairement les gens qui sont
opposés à l'avortement aux États-Unis
sont également opposés à la
contraception merci beaucoup écoutez
pour cette table ronde absolument
passionnante et enrichissante et donc
maintenant je vous propose que nous
passions à la table ronde suivante qui
sera animée par Laurence rignol que
j'appelle à mes
côtés sur le sujet de quel blocage et
quel accès effectif avec nel data Jeanne
éès et Amandine clavau et du coup je
vais me décaler d'un d'un rang pour
les Laurence à ma place et les
intervenants à
côté
bien on va poursuivre ce qui a été
engagé avec la première table ronde et
vous allez voir que les sujets qu'on va
aborder dans celle-ci sont absolument
dans la continuité de la précédente et
en particulier nous allons nous
intéresser à deux deux angles de vue le
premier qui est la question de savoir
euh comment se font les obstacles à
l'IVG y compris lorsque les législations
prétendent garantir le droit à l'IVG euh
comme et aussi la deuxième le deuxème
aspect de cette table ronde c'est de
nous intéresser à euh ces adversaires de
l'IVG euh qui sont-ils d'où viennent-ils
quels sont leurs réseaux et surtout
quels sont leurs financements aussi et
euh on va voir que on a affaire à des
mouvements qui sont organisés et euh ont
beaucoup de moyens avant juste de passer
la parole de petites remarques
incidentes qui me sont venues à l'esprit
en écoutant la table ronde précédente la
première c'est que quand Anne l a évoqué
LEC right Act ou l' amendment pour
celles et ceux qui voudrai en savoir
plus en se distrayant je recommande une
formidable série qui s'appelle Miss
America pour qu vous l'auriez pas vu qui
est
sur la meilleure plateforme française la
seule d'ailleurs une des meilleures
plateformes françaises de voilà qui est
sur Canal maintenant c'est dit on
enlèvera pour la
retransmission mais trop tard je sais
trop tard c'est en direct mais bon euh
voilà et et qui raconte justement
l'histoire du mouvement féministe
américain au début des années 70 et la
bataille sur l'qual right Act vraiment
je vous la recommande je la recommande
aux collègues pour le leurs prochaines
vacances et la deuxième remarque que je
voulais faire c'est qu'en écoutant vous
partager quelque chose avec vous c'est
que j'ai été convaincu par des
obstétriciennes des gynécologues qui ont
un long fait un long travail sur l'accès
à l'IVG pratique je ne parle plus de
grossesse non
désirée parce que la question du désir
est une question infiniment plus
complexe que celle de la volonté et je
pense que on peut avoir des grossesses
peut-être un peu désirées mais pas voulu
pas programmé pas choisi et je parle
plutôt maintenant de grossesse imprévu
ou de grossesse non voulu voilà c'était
cette petite remarque que je soumets à
la réflexion de de celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent et d'abord de vous-même et
donc on va évoquer de dans cet instant
les relais politiques et les moyens dont
il se dotent pour faire contourner et
priver les femmes droit l'IVG nous avons
pour cela trois intervenants dans cette
deuxème table ronde que je vais vous
présenter Nil data directeur exécutif du
forum parlementaire européen pour les
droits sexuels et reproductifs qui est
un réseau de députés européens engagé
pour la promotion des droits sexuels et
reproductifs et qui nous dira peut-être
ce qu'il en est des Pays-Bas parce que
comme je passe pas mon temps à lire tous
les programmes de toutes les extrêmes
droites européennes dans le détail euh
je ne sais pas ce que cela raconte sur
l'accès à l'avortement ce voilà mais
donc je vousajoute cette question là si
vous pouvez répondre euh Jean ees qui
est chargé de plaidoyer pour l'Ong
International international iPass et
dont les travaux mettent en lumière
l'exportation des mouvements antichois à
l'international au sein des sphères de
l'ONU et en Afrique tout
particulièrement puis Amandine clavau
qui est directrice desétudes directrice
d'observatoire égalité femmes hommes de
la fondation jeanerè co-autrice d'un
excellent rapport intitulé droits des
femmes combattre le backlash qui a été
publié en février dernier dans un
partenariat entre l'ONG éipop et la
Fondation Jean jorè et qui poursuivra
les sujets qu'on a que que j'ai indiqué
donc nildata vous commencez cette table
ronde merci beaucoup
oui donc j'ai une présentation qui est
en train de télécharger et donc pendant
que ça se fait j'aimerais tout d'abord
remercier Madame Rossignol et madame la
Présidente pour cette invitation comme
on a évoqué not mon organisation est une
organisation de parlementaires et c'est
pas je trouve particulièrement élégant
d'être ici au Sénat en France car il y a
23 ans c'est ici que notre organisation
a été fondée grâce en fait au sénateur
Lucien nevirt et qui est bien connu dans
ce domaine et donc donc c'est vraiment
un réel plaisir d'être ici parmi vous
euh maintenant je vais aborder les
questions des mouvements anti antichoix
antiggenre et comment ils sont organisés
je crois que ça va répondre à certaines
des questions qui ont été évoquées lors
de la Table Ronde précédente donc je
vais regarder trois questions en
particulier qui sont-ils et comment
elles sont financés leurs idées leurs
stratégies et ensuite je vais terminer
sur quelques conclusions et je vais me
je vais me permettre d'aborder quelques
sujets qui ont été et euh évoqué lors de
de la discussion précédente
ok donc qui sont-ils donc voici une
soupe de logo de différents mouvements
euh anti-ens qui sont actifs
principalement en Europe donc vous voyez
certains certaines organisations qui
sont présentes à l'échelle nationale
vous vous allez reconnaître la Fondation
Jérôme Lejeune ici en France le
eclg le centre européen pour le droit et
la justice qui est basé à Strasbourg il
y a des organisations nation
dans différents pays européens et des
organisations de la droite chrétienne
américaine qui se sont
internationalisé ici en Europe et on va
revenir sur tout ça donc et aussi bon on
se rappelle tous de la manive pour tous
il y a 10
ans donc qui sont ces groupes d'abord il
faut il faut comprendre que ce sont
essentiellement en Europe des nouveaux
acteurs dans la société donc cette
nouvelle contestation et j'aborde une
question qui a été évoquée euh lors de
la discussion précédente cette nouvelle
cette contestation sur les droits l'IVG
d'autres questions de de progrès social
ne viennent pas du bas ce ne sont pas
issus de de de la société ces
contestations viennent de certaines
organisations bien précises et c'est
c'est cette ce sont ces organisations
qui sont bien organisées qui ensuite
mènent cette contestation ok donc ça je
crois qu'il faut bien comprendre ce qui
se passe et donc là ces nouveaux acteurs
ce sont essentiellement des ONG des
Think Tank des certains partis
politiques nouvellement créés
euh ils sont euh ils sont souvent
d'inspiration religieuse mais surtout
dans un contexte européen vont se
camoufler de cette inspiration
religieuse donc ils vont apparaître
comme étant laïque et ne vont pas mettre
en avant leur leurs convictions
religieuses mais vont mettre en avant
éventuellement d'autres d'autres
apparences ils sont pour la la liberté
de pensée pour la liberté de religion et
cetera pour le droit des parents et par
exemple ok aussi une chose c'est qu'ils
sont euh ils occupent une place
intéressante sur les chiquers politiques
ils sont proches de la droite
traditionnelle et aussi de de l'extrême
droite de la la droite alternative comme
on l'appelle dans certains pays et donc
ils peuvent fréquenter les deux milieux
assez aisément ok euh aussi parmi les
cibles ok euh ça c'est c'est le
professeur léger qui l'a évoqué euh lors
de la discussion précédente on peut
identifier cinq cibles principales
d'abord il y a tout ce qui est santé
procréation reproduction ok IVG
contraception et cetera il y a ensuite
les droits sexuels il y a ensuite les
les les les droits LGBT ok donc le
mariage pour tous et cetera il y a
ensuite toutes les questions de genre ok
donc là il faut pas trop réfléchir à
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire ou qu'est-ce
que eux pensent sont les les questions
de genre il suffit de mettre la le mot
genre quelque part pour provoquer une
une réaction allergique ok aussiou c'est
pareil
ok un 4ème sujet sont les droits des
enfants ok ça c'est un sujet que souvent
dans une enceinte comme celle-ci on a
tendance à oublier mais le droit des
enfants surtout en particulier qui qui a
le dernier mot pour décider de du
bien-être de l'enfant est-ce la famille
traditionnelle patriarcale et cetera ou
bien parce que l'État aurait le droit
d'intervenir dans certains pays par
exemple les pays nordiques il y a un
système assez interventionniste pour
protéger le droit de l'enfant qui est
reconnu comme ayant des droits à part
entière au-delà de celui de la famille
ah c'est parti ma présentation et puis
ensuite il y a aussi les questions de de
de liberté de religion là l'argument
c'est de c'est c'est vraiment de dire
que ma liberté de religion est plus
importante que sa liberté que son droit
d'accès à à des à des soins de santé ou
d'autres personnes de d'être protégé par
contre des discriminations si je peux
prétendre que c'est grâce à ma religion
que je pratique cette discrimination ok
d'habitude cette liberté de religion
s'applique essentiellement aux chrétiens
pas les autres religions OK et en
général on a constaté une laïcisation
une sécularisation du langage donc au
lieu de vieilles idées religieus on on
le pass on on fait passer ces idées par
une une genre de less pour en faire
ressortir des des idées et un
vocabulaire qui ressemble à celui des
droits humains modernes
ok donc on a quelques grandes tendances
avec ces acteurs antidroit anti antigre
il y a d'abord une
professionnalisation donc là vous voyez
une carte de l'Europe avec où sont où
sont implanté certaines organisation de
la droite chrétienne américaine et là
vous voyez Londres Bruxelles Strasbourg
Genève Vienne et Rome ok ils ne sont pas
à Paris pas à Berlin pas à Madrid ça
c'est pas ils ont choisi ces villes
parce que ce sont les centres
d'institution internationales qui
abordent les questions des droits
humains OK et c'est pour ça qu' il y a
une concentration à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg et à Genève donc euh et et
avec cette professionnalisation ils
savent comment fonctionnent les
institutions internationales ils savent
ils savent produire un projet de loi un
amendement et cetera ils ont des relais
des alliés politiques qui peuvent faire
avancer leurs propres idées deuxièmement
il y a une transnationalisation de ces
mouvements donc chacun de ces groupes
qui existent à l'échelle national donc
vous connaissez vos groupes en France il
y a des groupes semblables en Allemagne
en Suède aux Pays-Bas et cetera
maintenant ils ont ils se réunissent et
ils organisent des réunions où ils
partagent des bonnes idées des
stratégies et cetera nous connaissons
plusieurs types de ce de ce genre de
réunion le Congrès mondial des familles
agenda Europe et le réseau politique des
valeurs que Jeanne va nous expliquer
j'imagine un petit peu plus tard et puis
et pour ces questions de
transnationalisation j'ai amené un
rapport ici intitulé restaurer l'ordre
naturel qui explique comment ils se sont
organisés à partir de 2013 pour former
des stratégies et puis lancer des
initiatives dans une petite quinzaine de
pays donc concernant les financements
donc ça c'est quelque chose que que nous
avons regardé donc nous avons identifié
tous les mouvements antig-genre qui
existe en Europe nous en on a pu en
répertorier plus d'une C vingtaine ok
ensuite nous avons nous avons fait
simplement le travail de recherche pour
trouver leurs détails financiers leurs
comptes annuels et cetera leurs bilan et
nous l'avons trouvé pour 54 d'entre de
ces organisations dans la région Europe
donc pour la décennie qui qui va de 2009
à 2018 sur ces 54 organisations des ONG
des fondations et cetera nous avons pu
identifier plus de 700 millions de
dollars euh qui allaient dans ce
mouvement en Europe OK et donc si on
regarde de plus près ces 700 millions de
dollars on peut constater que au début
de la décennie ils étaient à moins de 20
millions de dollars par an à la fin de
la décennie en 2018 ils étaient à plus
de 80 millions de dollars par an donc si
votre budget augmente par un facteur de
4 vous pouvez faire bien plus de choses
on est en train de mettre jour ses
données pour pour les sortir en amont
des élections européennes l'année
prochaine et je peux dire que même
maintenant les financements ont
davantage augmenté nous parlons plutôt
de 120 130 millions de dollars par an en
région Europe OK et donc et si on
regarde de plus près d'où vient cet
argent il y a trois zones géographiques
d'origine d'abord les États-Unis donc la
droite chrétienne américaine
s'internation s'est internationalisée et
est présente ici en Europe avec des
bureaux permanents ce qui est
intéressant à retenir des des Américains
c'est qu'ils amènent le l'expérience
professionnelle américaine dans les dans
les sciences juridiques donc tout donc
ce sont des avocats qui établissent des
bureaux d'avocats ici en Europe et
ensuite cherche des contentieux
juridiques pour les mener devant les
Cours ensuite il y a la Russie
essentiellement des oligarques qui
financent des mouvements d'extrême
droite des partis politiques d'extrême
droite je crois que vous en êtes consci
ici en en France avec quels seraient les
acteurs qui pourraient
être concernés mais la plupart des
financements plus de 400 plus de 430
millions vient d'Europe même donc ce
sont nos riches qui financent ce
mouvement extrémiste en Europe ce
mouvement antidroit dans certains pays
il bénéficient d'un soutien de l'État
par exemple la Hongrie la Pologne et et
et d'autres pays
aussi donc je vais aborder maintenant
certains de leurs idées leurs stratégies
ok donc d'abord il y avait il y avait un
réseau intitulé agenda Europe qui était
bien organisé qui s'est qui organisait
des réunions annuelles qui rassemblaient
plus d'une centaine des mouvements
antigenre antichoix à l'échelle
européenne dans un sommet annuel et ils
avaient un un manifeste commun intitulé
restaurer l'ordre naturel et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il préconise dans ce
manifeste qui un manifeste d'une 130ain
de page d'abord euh leurs croyances ne
sont leurs idées ne sont pas fondées sur
des croyances religieuses mais sur la
loi naturelle ok donc là un exemple de
laïcisation de leur langage mais si on
si on connaît bien ce ces acteur loi
naturelle fait référence à certains
principes catholiques et donc c'est un
genre de code pour renvoyer à certaines
idées religieuses tout en passant pour
laïque à un public plus large ok
catholique ou chrétien parce que les
mouvements évangéliques sont aussi très
présents l'origine de la plupart
l'origine intellectuelle de ces idées
est essentiellement catholique et puis
ensuite a été adopté par d'autres
confessions chrétiennes
OK et là on peut voir que leur façon
d'organiser leur pensée n'est pas d'être
contre certaines idées ils ne sont pas
contre l'IVG ils sont pas contre les
droits sexuel et cetera mais ils sont
pour des certaines idées ils sont pour
la vie pour la vie dès le moment de la
conception jusqu'à la mort naturelle et
donc là vous voyez IVG euthanasie droit
de mourir en dignité font partie de la
même chose famille famille
traditionnelle patriarcale
hétérosexuelle et pour la liberté la
liberté religieuse essentiellement ma
liberté religieuse est plus importante
que vos droits et puis vos
protections et là si on regarde
à pardon ok donc je vais je vais
terminer ok oui OK puis vous reviendrez
après ok donc je en fait je vais je vais
sauter certaines certaines euh slides et
puis euh un des réseaux importants un
des réseaux importants c'est c'est le
réseau politique des valeurs qui s'est
réuni à Bruxelles euh en 2017 et puis
avait son propre plan d'action et donc
là c'est un c'est un extrait de ce plan
d'action et là vous pouvez voir sur les
question d'IVG ils ont une stratégie la
stratégie c'est celle de prévention
restriction et interdiction et donc pour
prévention ça ne veut pas dire
promouvoir l'accès à la contraception et
cetera c'est vraiment créer des
obstacles à tout ce qui est la femme et
son accès à
l'IVG reconnu par selon le droit légal
là j'ai je crois que j'ai abusé de mon
temps donc je vais terminer sur ceci
merci vous n'avez pas abusé de votre
temps mais comme il faut le partager ce
temps et puis que vous êtes un peu tous
les trois sur euh des travaux identiques
je propose que la parole va être
maintenant à l'intervenante suivante et
j'ai oublié votre prénom mais il va me
revenir tout de suite jeanè Jeanne voilà
nom de famille avec jeanè et puis CAV et
puis vous reprendraz la parole après les
trois interventions pour compléter ce
qui n'aura pas été dit par vos amis
d'accord je c'est à vous merci beaucoup
bonjour à tous et bonjour à toutes donc
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas iPass
nous sommes une organisation Internet
national donc l'unique mission est
vraiment d'élargir l'accès à
l'avortement ça passe par le
renforcement des systèmes de santé
l'accompagnant de gouvernement la
création de stratégie politiqu qui vise
vraiment à la dépénalisation on a des
bureaux dans une vingtaine de pays à
travers le monde surtout l'avortement
est fortement criminalisé donc comme EPF
ça fait plus de 15 ans que nous traquons
le mouvement antigre cette recherche
vise à démasquer et à bien sûr
désenclavé les offensives de ces acteurs
avec nos partenaires de terrain les
médias l'associ société civile le monde
médical et le monde féministe il est
impossible pour nous de sécuriser nos
acquis aujourd'hui sans vraiment
comprendre nos détracteurs et c'est donc
ça dont je vais parler aujourd'hui donc
comme l'a bien dit Nil ces acteurs et
surtout ce dont nous parlons ce matin
ils sont spécifiquement engagé contre
l'idéologie de genre et ils utilisent
l'opposition à ce qu'on appelle les dssr
donc les droits à la santé sexuelle et
reproductive et les droits LGBT comme un
principe d'organisation pour attirer des
fonds et de l'influence politique à des
fins discriminatoires et des fins
antidémocratique aujourd'hui nous
considérons que les défis qui sont posés
aux espaces nationaux régionaux et
internationaux sont sans précédent et
qu'on assiste à une grande à une
destruction en grande partie des acquis
de nos droits humains du siècle dernier
alors qu pour dans la continuité de ce
dont n vient de parler qu'est-ce que la
GPA donc la gestation pour autrui
l'accord de commerce de Cotonou de
l'Union européenne la peine de mort qui
criminalise l'homosexualité en Ouganda
et le droit à l'avortement peuvent avoir
en commun et bien ces thématiqu qui
pourrait sembler très distinctes ont
tout été vivement abordé la semaine
dernière au siège de l'ONU lors d'un
rassemblement antidroit de la plus haute
envergure à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme le 5e sommet
transatlantique organisé sous le thème
unir les cultures pour la vie la famille
et les libertés était organisé par le
réseau politique pour les valeurs celui
dont n vient de parler le pnfv et ses
alliés donc le PNV est une plateforme
d'origine ibérique et c'est une des
plateformes ultra conservatrices les
plus puissantes du monte elle tente
d'influencer des politiques
internationales en travaillant de très
près avec des Think Tank ultra
conservateurs des ONG fondamentalistes
et d'extrême droite américaine ainsi que
des fondations privées chrétiennes et
des pays comme la Hongrie je signale
aussi que cathaline Novac en était la
présidente jusqu'à il y a quelques
années donc ça fait plus de 10 ans que
le pnfv se consacre à renverser le
système des Nations Unies et à éroder le
droit de population historiquement
marginalisée donc la semaine dernière on
a vu plus de 200 dirigeants politiques
et civiques de 40 pays à New York le
ministre de la Protection de l'Enfance
de l'équateur la ministre des femmes du
Nigéria des députés du Paraguay de la
Finlande du Panama de la Colombie du
Brésil des membres du Parlement européen
Sam George un député du Ghana qui a été
instrumental dans la loi visant à
criminaliser les droits LGBT au Ghana
ainsi que Lucy akelo une députée de
l'Ouganda qui a aussi joué un rôle
central dans la légalis dans la dans la
loi pénalisant l'homosexualité en
Ouganda le député de l'Argentine et
c'est à propos il a dit il n'est pas
possible qu'aujourd'hui l'endroit le
plus dangereux au monde soit l'utérus là
où la vie humaine est la plus menacée
cette réunion donc de partage de bonnes
pratiques et du renforcement des
synergies intervient un moment de grande
anxiété mondiale en particulier face aux
efforts visant à affaiblir les espaces
multilatéraux comme l'ONU et par ce même
B les droits des femmes elle montre à
quel point le mouvement antidroit a
pénétré des hautes sphères du pouvoir et
comme il est aligné autour de certaines
thématiques opportunistes pour un agenda
mondial commun qui va au-delà de de
l'urap donc ce qu'on constate ces
dernières années comme l'a dit Nil c'est
une une question d'échelle des
offensives une rapidité une
sophistication de leur stratégie avec
une augmentation de ces réseaux qui sont
originaires d'Europe et des États-Unis
donc je vais parler ici de quelques
stratégies sans trop aller dans le
détail vous l'avez bien compris on voit
le ciblage du genre et de la diversité
de genre à l'ONU et dans les espaces
diplomatiques régionaux donc depuis
quelques temps on fait face à une
paralysie normative pendant les
négociations voir par parfois des
régressions en tout cas un
ralentissement pour toutes les
négociations qui ont à voir avec
lesidssr le genre et qui sont censés les
promouvoir notamment pendant la
commission annuelle sur le statut de la
femme donc l'opposition attaque
directement le système de l'ONU elle
prône le retrait des accords le le le
définancement pardon et la
délégitimation de ces agences elle
discrédite les mécanismes tout en en
abusant d'une stratégie d'entrrisme donc
en formant des diplomates euh a
participer à ces réseaux en créant des
ONG et des systèmes parallèles de droits
humains euh euh qui n'ont aucune
légitimité légal comme le consensus de
Genève donc ils utilisent les cours
régionales comme l'a dit Nil des droits
humains pour une mise en réseau
transnational permanente avec une une
approche qui est beaucoup plus
technocratique qu'avant avec une
orientation constitutionnelle qui
s'inspire beaucoup de groupes juridiques
américains et qui investissent du coup
dans le renforcement de capacité à
l'international en litige stratégique
anti-avortement donc on voit des groupes
par exemple autrichiens qui mettent sur
place des réseaux euh de litigateur en
uganta par exemple Provis il a c'est pas
juste au niveau des nations- Unies on le
voit aussi au niveau de la Cour
interaméricaine qui est menacée depuis
2013 de coût budgétaire du parti
républicain américain qui l'accuse de de
violer la souveraineté nationale au nom
du droit à l'avortement et des droits
LGBT dans les Amériques on entend c'est
mê mêmes arguments à l'Union africaine
et contre la Commission européenne le le
groupe eclj dont dont n parlait à
l'instant a publié son deuxème rapport
l'année dernière qui met en lumière la
soi-disant collusion entre
l'organisation open Society Foundation
de George Soros et les cours de la
Commission européenne on les retrouve
aussi là on les attend un petit peu
moins donc à l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé certes mais aussi par exemple
avec l'accord de Cotonou donc c'est un
accord économique entre les États
d'Afrique des Caraïbes et de l'Union
européenne qui repose sur trois piliers
de coopération développement économique
et commercial a priori cet accord
n'avait pas connu de controverse depuis
ces 20 ans d'existence mais des
dispositions récentes qui ont été
introduites sur le genre et sur la santé
en ont fait un cheval de tro de
l'opposition là on a vu un think tank
neerlandoaméricain donc le Christian
Council international le politique en
network for values dont je parlais une
organisation américaine family watch
internationale lancer une croisade sans
précédent contre l'accord commercial
européen avec un un lobbying intense
enprès de gouvernement africain et
caribéen ils ont donc dévié le langage
démonisé la nature de l'accord
provoquant au niveau national en Habibi
au Nigéria des conférences de presse des
mobilisations des pétitions et ils ont
fait un excellent travail et quand je
dis excellent c'est parce que ça a
suscité l'indignation de certains
gouvernements qui ont menacé de son
retrait il y a des gouvernements qui se
sont euh qui se sont retiré de l'accord
et ça a surtout ralenti euh les
négociations suite à l'adoption du
projet de loi qui a criminalisé
l'homosexualité par le Parlement
ougandais en avril 2023 ces mêmes
groupes donc les groupes
transnationonaux dont j'étais en train
de parler ont organisé une conférence
interparlementaire régionale où ils ont
décrit l'accord commercial comme une
menace existentielle pour les familles
et les enfants africains à la tête de
ces accusations on trouve les dirigeants
européens du Christian con international
et de Family watch international qui ont
été félicité par la première dame de
l'ouanda Janette moussevini donc je vous
laisse apprécier un petit peu l'ironie
de de ces rapports pour rappel bien sûr
la loi qui vient d'êt passer en ouanda
et le fruit de longes années de travail
de groupes qui sont aussi internationaux
que nationaux bien sûr donc ces groupes
dont on est en train de parler
aujourd'hui comme family watch
International et leurs partenaires
parlementaires font tout pour affaiblir
les lois et les normes internationales
qui ège l'égalité de genre l'avortement
et le droit des minorités en Afrique ils
sont également très mobilisés contre
l'éducation complète à la sexualité les
directive de l'UNESCO en mobilisant
comme l' dit Nil la panique morale les
droits parentaux en citant un complot
féministe international promouvant
l'homosexualité et la masturbation des
enfants et donc des États-Unis au Panama
au Sénégal on trouve une grande
collusion entre ces groupes ultra
conservateurs et des écoles au niveau
local et vous connaissez ce problème
également en France donc ça peut
ressembler à des censures à des
mouvements sentiers pornographie pour
l'éducation à la maison et cetera on le
voit aussi comme on le dit depuis ce
matin l'instrumentalisation du pouvoir
judiciaire donc on l'a vu l'année
dernière avec la chute de rovy Wade et
comme pendant les la période du Global
gag Grou donc la règle de Mexico City
qui censure et qui coupe les
financements des organisations
internationales et des structures
médicales qui offrent les services
d'avortement qui est mis en place
pendant des administrations républiqu we
en tout cas qu'il a été fait depuis
depuis les 20 dernières années on voit
que la ROV Wade a déjà eu des impacts
négatifs sur des processus législatifs à
l'international donc au Kenya et au
nigerriia il y a déjà eu des motions
d'arrêter de processus législativ
progressif qui était en faveur de des
dssr où l'AR rovy Wade a été cité on le
voit également en Éthiopie il y a eu un
effet électrifiant en fait pour le
mouvement
anti-avortement en Afrique mais on l'a
aussi vu en Inde où il a été cité aussi
par des mouvements
anti-avortement et donc ces groupes
travaillent en partenariat ou pour les
organisations dont N et moi éta en train
de parler parce qu'une des dynamiques
qu'on voit depuis ces dernières années
c'est une une localisation en fait du
staff de ces organisations américaines
et européennes qui vont engager un
leadership africain ouvrir des bureaux à
l'Union africaine et et engager en fait
des visages locaux pour pour leur
plaidoyer euh donc ces groupes
deviennent plus créatif plus efficace il
s'inspire aussi nous de notre activisme
il gagne en visibilité un groupe qui
était sur sur les logos de la soupe de
nî et donc citizen Go qui a un groupe
ultra conservateur d'origine espagnole
de mobilisation digitale ce groupe a été
instrumental dans la fermeture de soins
de santé de la reproduction au Kenya
sous prétexte qu'ils offrai des soins
des soins d'avortement illégaux et ce
qu'on constate aussi c'est euh une
prolifération du du militantisme
anti-avortement à
l'américaine donc on va le voir avec des
vigiles devant des cliniques par exemple
des marches pour la vie au Nigéria et
quelque chose qui est encore assez
discret pour l'instant en Afrique mais
qui ne serurait tardé à à à être
amplifié c'est la stratégie des centres
de crise de de grossesse en crise une
stratégie qui est très utilisée en
Europe et aux États-Unis qui consiste à
offrir des soins de S gratuit aux femmes
pauvres en le en bien sûr les incitant à
ne pas avorter essayer de les convaincre
de garder leur grossesse ça peut aussi
passer par des formations du corps
médical en objection de conscience ça
c'est une nouvelle stratégie que l'on
voit et donc se concentrer sur les
assistantes sociales les infirmières
pour les
inciter à objecter ce qui est quand même
particulièrement pernicieux voilà donc
vous l'avez compris tout ceci a un
impact direct sur la vie des femmes sur
leur choix reproductif sur les personnes
LGBT et sur leur famille et ça enflamme
vraiment les hostilités au niveau
communautaire au niveau national même si
l'opposition n'est pas forcément
nouvelle ou importé l'extrémiste et le
populisme viennent aggraver ces
initiatives et se lient à d'autres
tendances mondiales antiféministes et
nationaliste et le genre devient le
véhicule de politique antidémocratique
et permet une normalisation de ces
discours extrémistes avec des
passerelles soi-disant inoffensive comme
le droit des parents voilà donc pour
conclure je dirais qu'il est temps de
réfléchir à des collective et
d'entériner nos soutiens aux actions et
organisations de terrain de recherche au
renforcement des institutions
démocratiques et à la survie et au
maintien des espaces multilatéraux il
faut forger un consensus politique
auprès de nos instensces sur la valeur
fondamentale et inaliignable de ces
droits et de leur interdépendance dont
l'accès à l'avortement et la santé
sexuelle et reproductive est bien sûr
une pierre angulaire je vous
remercie merci Jeanne merci Amandine
maintenant c'est à vous
bonjour à à toutes et à tous merci tout
d'abord à à la délégation au droits des
femmes et à l'égalité des chances du
Sénat pour cette invitation dire un mot
rapide sur la Fondation Jean jorè pour
celles et ceux qui ne nous connaîtrai
pas nous sommes une fondation politique
reconnue d'utilité publique et à ce
titre là on travaille sur l'ensemble des
des politiques publiques dont les
questions égalité femmes hommes font
partie et sur lesquels nous sommes
particulièrement engagés
notamment en matière de défense des
droits et santé sexuelle et reproductif
et donc pour cette intervention je vais
m'appuyer sur le rapport que nous avons
produit donc qui est ici droit des
femmes droit des femmes combattre le
backlash avec éipop et également sur
l'essai que j'ai écrit droits des femmes
le grand recul qui traite notamment de
l'impact de la crise sanitaire sur les
droits des femmes en Europe donc on l'a
vu dans la première table
ronde concernant le droit à l'avortement
que celui-ci est protégé par des textes
internationaux mais qu'en dépit de de
tout ça il y a un certain nombre
d'obstacles qui sont structurels
politiques
législatifs il y a une hétérogénité de
ces cadres législatifs qui existent et
donc on l'a vu l'avortement est autorisé
dans seulement 77 pays il est
complètement interdit dans 22 pays ça
pour cons ence en fait que près d'une
femme sur deux d'après un rapport du
FNUAP ne dispose pas librement de son
corps dans le monde autre conséquen près
d'une IVG sur de et donc réalisé dans
des conditions non sécurisées pour les
femmes d'après le goutmer Institute
parce qu'on le sait une femme qui ne
souhaite pas poursuivre une grossesse
mettra tout en œuvre pour cela en dépit
des dispositifs législatifs qui les
interdiraiit si on se penche sur le
l'accès à l'avortement dans l'Union ion
européenne il est autorisé dans 25 États
membres sur sur 27 Malte et la Pologne
l'interdisent quasiment
totalement il faut aussi rappeler que
Andor et le Vatican l'interdisent aussi
et je vais m'arrêter sur plusieurs
exemples au niveau
européen notamment notamment en terme de
stratégie la traduction politique que
ces mouvements antidroits arrivent à
mettre en œuvre lorsqu'ils sont au
pouvoir et donc principalement qu'on
retrouve au sein de partis d'extrême
droite et de la droite populiste et donc
le cas de de la Pologne qui est assez
emblématique il est aujourd'hui
quasiment impossible d'avorter en
Pologne sauf en cas de danger pour la
vie de la femme de viol ou d'inceste
cette législation elle est en place
depuis janvier 2021 elle est issue d'une
longue bataille qui a été menée par le
Parti conservateur droit et justice
depuis son arrivé arriv au pouvoir en en
2015 et qui n'a donc pas cessé de
vouloir interdire cet accès des des
femmes à à
l'IVG ils ont d'ailleurs profité de la
crise sanitaire pour essayer de passer
ce projet de de loi parce que les
confinements permettaiit pas la
mobilisation des des populations et ils
ont voulu faire en sorte que les IVG
soient considérés comme comme non
essentiel ce projet de loi n'est pas
passé à ce moment-là mais il a abouti
donc en en janvier 2021 on estime qu'il
y a environ 200000 avortements euh
clandestins pardon qui ont été réalisés
par an depuis la mise en place de de
cette législation en janvier 2021 le
collectif avortement sans frontière a
réalisé a aidé pardon 33000 femmes à
avorter entre janvier 2021 et janvier
2022 et surtout la première des
conséquences c'est qu'on déplore la mort
de plusieurs femmes polonaises
parce que les médecins ont refusé
d'intervenir par peur de poursuite
judiciaire parce qu'il risque 3 ans de
de prison et donc en fait c'est la santé
des femmes et en réalité leur vie qui
est clairement mis en danger autre
élément de de crimin criminalisation des
femmes les médecins sont obligés de
notifier dans un registre les femmes
enceintes depuis la mise en place d'un
arrêté ministériel en juin 2022 autre
autre élément euh les militantes
féministes sont particulièrement
menacées je j'en veux pour preuve Martha
Lampart qui est cofondatrice du
mouvement la greffe des femmes est
actuellement menacée de mort elle est
placée sous protection judiciaire ou
encore le cas de justina vridrinska qui
est une militante féministe qui a été
reconnue coupable par la justice d'avoir
prêté assistance à l'IVG à la pratique
d'une IVG et condamné à 8 mois de
travaux d'intérêt général et enfin
dernier élément dernière trouvaille dans
la criminalisation des femmes polonaises
un laboratoire polonais à la demande du
gouvernement conservateur a mis au point
un test qui permettrait de savoir si une
femme a eu recours ou non à une IVG
médicamenteuse et donc là je vais
m'arrêter sur les élections législatives
qui ont eu lieu qui ont vu la victoire
du bloc libéral et de centregauche et
qui là en fait montre un marque un vrai
tournant parce qu'on l'a vu l'avortement
a été en fait un élément de mobilisation
de la part des jeunes et notamment des
jeunes où leur participation a été
beaucoup plus importante qu'au scruin
précédent et une mobilisation également
de la part des femmes à noter l'opinion
publique polonaise est en fait très
largement favorable à la à l'avortement
à près de 84 % donc on voit bien en fait
un yatus entre ce gouvernement
conservateur et l'opinion publique c'est
exactement la même chose d' d'ailleurs
qu'on retrouve aux États-Unis où
l'avortement est très largement partagé
par la population et donc là il va
falloir suivre ça avec particulièrement
d'attention pour voir si donn tulsk qui
qui pardon et le leader de l'opposition
a promis de libéraliser l'avortement
arrivera à faire passer ces ces
propositions de loi la gauche a déjà
déposé deux propositions de loi mais en
fait la la réalité pour la promulgation
de de ces lois il faut la signature du
président Juda et ce président est
proche du parti Droit et Justice donc il
y a une vraie bataille qui va qui va
s'enclencher et qui va falloir suivre
avec
attention l'autre exemple que je voulais
évoquer c'est le cas de la Hongrie et
donc dans cet exemple là c'est assez
intéressant parce que là la Pologne on
parlait d'un cadre législatif qui était
contraignant en Hongrie le l'avortement
est autorisé jusqu'à 12 12 semaines et
pourtant dans les faits il est de plus
en plus difficile d'y accéder le
gouvernement de Victor de Victor Orban
qui est donc un un conservateur n'a
cessé de multiplier ses atteintes et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a oblige les
femmes qui souhaitent avorter à écouter
les battements du cœur du fetus pour les
dissuader d'avorter à noter que le chef
de de ce gouvernement là a été l'hôte
d'un sommet sur la démographie où on
retrouvait tous les acteurs que nel et
Jean ont ont cité euh tous ces acteurs
donc antidroit parce que nous dans notre
rapport on parle de mouvement anti-droit
ces acteurs-là ils s'attaquent comme on
l'a dit au droits des femmes au droits
des personnes LGBT au droits des
personnes migrantes donc c'est
l'ensemble des droits humains qu'ils
attaquent et donc pour eux le finalement
la bataille contre le droit à
l'avortement ça va de paire avec une
politique nataliste et donc pour eux ils
considèrent que les femmes doivent faire
davantage d'enfants et Victor Orban a
trouvé une allié de choix puisque la la
présidente cathaline Novak était
présente à un sommet international à
womanen
deliver qui était qui se tenait donc à
Kigali en en juillet dernier et elle est
intervenue pour parler de leur politique
en matière d'égalité femme homme en en
disant que leur politique et leur
objectif principal c'était
l'augmentation de la fécondité et elle
déclarait même qu'elle espérait que sa
fille ait 10 enfants si elle le
souhaitait
on va passer maintenant de de l'autre
côté des Alpes et j'aimerais parler
maintenant du cas de l'Italie où là
aussi l'avortement est autorisé jusqu'à
jusqu'à 12 semaines depuis la loi de
1978 mais on le sait cet avortement il
est très difficile d'accès en raison de
la clause de conscience qui est invoquée
par près de 70 à 90 % des médecins dans
certaines régions et ça ce sont des
chiffres du ministère de la Santé en
Italie de 2021 et depuis l'arrivée de
Georgia Meloni qui est donc cette leader
leader du parti d'extrême droite
Fratelli d'Italia et bien les craintes
sont réel par rapport à la remise en
cause du droit à l'avortement elle a
fait campagne sur plusieurs slogans et
dont notamment l'un et de du droit de ne
pas avorter euh et elle souhaite mettre
en place euh un fond pour supprimer les
causes économiques et social qui aurait
conduit les femmes à à l'avortement euh
si on regardeg ement son son
gouvernement elle a nommé une ministre
de la Famille et l'intitulé aussi de ce
portefeuille est intéressant ministre de
la Famille de la natalité de l'égalité
des chances Eugenia rochella qui est
connu pour ses positions anti-avortement
anti mariage pour tous dès son arrivée
au pouvoir il y a également eu une
proposition de loi qui a été portée par
un sénateur Mauricio Gaspari qui fait
partie du parti for Italia donc de
l'équivalent de de la droite et donc qui
a proposé de modifier l'article 1 du
Code civil pour faire en sorte de
remettre en cause le droit à
l'avortement et notamment en faisant
reconnaître le fitus comme une
personnalité juridique c'est exactement
là aussi un combat que l'on retrouve
actuellement aux États-Unis et enfin on
voyait déjà quand l'extrême droite était
au pouvoir à la tête de certaines
régions en Italie qu'il souhait remettre
en cause euh ce ce droit à l'avortement
ou en tout cas contourner les
dispositifs législatifs je il y a trois
exemples notamment dans le piémon où ils
ont mis en place des aides financières
pour convaincre les femmes à ne pas
avorter ils ont financé massivement là
aussi des associations
antichoix ou encore dans les dans les
marches donc cette région où en fait ils
ont tout simplement refusé d'appliquer
une direective nationale qui permet
l'accès à une IVG médicamenteuse euh
troisème exemple il y a une proposition
dans dans les abruses pour mettre en
place des sépultures pour fettus avorté
c'est une proposition qui a été soumise
plusieurs fois qui n'est pas passé mais
là en fait on voit bien en fait les
tentatives les tentatives répétées et
puis autre exemple Georgia Meloni elle
s'attaque aussi au droits des personnes
LGBTI plus et à leur droit et santé
sexuelle et reproductif elle a déclaré
oui à la famille naturelle non au lobby
LGBT et de de fait elle souhaite effacer
des actes de naissance le nom de la mère
non biologique pour les femmes pour les
couples de femmes qui qui auraient eu
pardon recours à la à la PMA donc on
voit bien là les multiples atteintes et
les différents fronts qui sont qui sont
attaqué et les réelles craintes que l'on
peut voir peser pour les femmes
italiennes et enfin dernier exemple
j'aimerais évoquer le cas de la Suède
parce que c'est un pays qui est très
souvent cité et à juste titre euh pour
pour sa politique en matière d'égalité
figure dans l'ensemble des des des des
comment dire des classements au niveau
internationaux mais euh pourtant les
menaces elles sont quand même là euh
parce que en dépit du fait que
l'avortement est autorisé depuis 18
semaines il faut rappeler que la jusqu'à
jusqu'à jusqu'à 18 semaines pardon euh
jusqu'à 18 semaines il faut rappeler que
l'arrivée au pouvoir de la coalition de
la droite et de l'extrême droite
pourrait pourrait nuire et fragiliser ce
droit je vais m'intéresser là au cas
notamment de la vice-présidente du
Parlement qui s'appelle Julia cronling
et qui est loin d'être anodine donc elle
est vice-présidente du Parlement elle
est très connue pour ses positions
anti-avortement
elle a déposé pas moins de 54 motions en
l'espace de 12 ans pour restreindre le
droit à l'avortement en Suède en
attaquant différents biiaiss que ce soit
le délai de recours que ce soit la
question de la limitation pour les IVG
tardives ou encore l'introduction pour
une clause de conscience qui pourtant
n'existe pas dans la loi suédoise autre
autre exemple également le gouvernement
suédois a annoncé dès son élection qu'il
souhaitait abandonner la diplomatie
féministe or la Suède était pourtant
l'un des pays pionniers à l'avoir mise
en place en 2014 donc on voit bien là
encore les différentses attaques qui qui
font qui font auxquels les femmes en
Europe font
face et donc par conséquent ce qu'on
voit dans les différents exemples que
j'ai cité hein que ce soit la Pologne la
Hongrie la Hongrie l'Italie ou la Suède
que ce soit des cadres législatif
restrictif ou non il y a toujours un
yatus là là aussi entre la loi et son
effectivité et les atteintes sont
multiples les les ressorts sont
exactement les mêmes et sont is issu
donc de ces mouvements mouvements
anti-droit qui trouvent leur traduction
politique au sein des partis d'extrême
droite et de la droite populiste et très
largement leur objectif principal c'est
d'attaquer en premier lieu les droits et
la santé sexuelle et reproductif des
femmes ce qui montre bien combien ces
droits-là sont fragiles et pour pour
conclure c'est pour cette raison que les
élections européennes de juin 2024 vont
être là aussi cruciales et déterminantes
et va nécessiter la isation de toutes et
tous parce que c'est dans ces enceintes
là aussi que les mouvements antidroits
trouvent leur traduction et arrivent à
peser dans les dans les décisions et
c'est pour cette raison que un ensemble
l'ensemble des associations féministes
souhaite que l'IVG soit inscrit dans la
Charte européenne des droits
fondamentaux et un autre élément que je
souhaitais aussi mentionné c'est la
question de la régulation face à la
régulation des plateformes et NOTAM
amment des des réseaux sociaux face à
ces face à ces mouvements parce que là
aussi c'est l'un des lieux sur lesquels
il prospère de manière assez massive en
usant de
désinformation notamment en utilisant
des sites Internet qui ont toute
l'allure de sites gouvernementaux or or
ces sitesl usent de désinformation ils
font en sorte par le biais notamment de
lignes d'écoute notamment de numéro de
numéro de téléphone où les femmes
peuvent appeler ou tout simplement en
véhiculant des fausses informations pour
dissuader les femmes d'avorter et ça
c'est aussi un des éléments sur laquelle
sur lequel l'Union européenne doit
absolument se mobiliser d'ailleurs en
France il y a un délit d'entrave à l'IVG
qui avait été adopté d'entrave à IVG
numérique qui a été adopté en 2017 sur
lequel il faudrait largement s'inspirer
au niveau européen
merci
merci euh avant de vous redonner la
parole
parce que je crois que vous avez des des
compléments à ajouter en fonction des
propos qui ont été tenus autour defin
dans la succession est-ce qu'il y a des
questions colombe brossell sénatrice de
Paris merci beaucoup bonjour à à toutes
et tous et merci à madame la Présidente
et aux animatricesur
et non que des animatrices ce matin
d'ailleurs pour ce ce début de colloque
absolument euh passionnant j'avais une
question vous avez évoqué au moins pour
les deux premiers intervenants puis
finalement aussi am monine clavot la
question de l'entrisme dans les
institutions qu'elles soient
international ou ou européennes et je je
me demandait s'il y avait à l'échelle
soit européenne soit internationale
d'ailleurs des stratégies d'entrisme
dans le milieu scolaire qu'il soit
d'ailleurs milieu scolaire ou
universitaire euh parce que j'ai en en
mémoire quelques stratégies extrêmement
françaises
dentrisme dans dans le milieu scolaire
qui mais exactement dans dans la droite
ligne de de ce que vous décriviez
monsieur data partant d'autres sujets
finalement arrivait extrêmement
rapidement à la dénonciation
et du du droit à à l'avortement et donc
je voulais savoir si c'était des
phénomènes qu'on retrouvit dans dans
d'autres pays et comment est-ce que ils
avaient été plus ou moins d'ailleurs
contrecarré dans dans ces différents
pays merci estce qu'il y a d'autres
questions non peut-être moi je je vais
en poser une euh qui est fondée sur ma
double expérience la première c'est
celle de la période des ABCD de
l'égalité qui a été pour moi un grand
moment euh puisque c en plus ça
convergerit avec le la manif pour tous
où j'ai effectivement constaté ce que
vous évoqueiez tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire le le bloc de pensée de ces
mouvements qui effectivement IVG et
aussi la liberté éducative et je me
rappelle avoir vécu un un formidable un
incroyable
orage sur Internet orage désagréable sur
Internet enfin chit SME sur internet
pour avoir dit dans une émiss les
enfants n'appartiennent pas à leurs
parents et ça avait donné lieu à tout un
mais vraiment des milliers de tweets
comme quoi je voulais retirer les
enfants de leur famille les donner à
l'état enfin bref tout comme ça j'avais
vu à ce momentl à quel point ce sujet
est important quand vous avez évoqué les
mouvements et en particulier le racine
religieus vous avez essentiellement
parlé des mouvements catholiques on a
aussi évoqué les mouvements chrétiens
mais moi j'ai souvenir dans lesabc de
l'égalité d'avoir aussi vu une forte
mobilisation des fondamentalistes
musulmans euh et dans les stratégies
d'infiltration des organisations
international je pense que la
répartition du travail est assez bien
faite et je vais savoir comment
s'organisent les convergences entre ces
mouvements qui sont supposés
politiquement être assez hostiles et
puis en même temps qu'ils sont d'accord
sur beaucoup de choses voilà et la
deuxème remarque que je voulais faire
c'est très important moi je je regrette
que il y ait pas plus de sénateurs qui
puiss rendre disponible ce matin et tout
à l'heure c'est évoqué par la présidente
de la conjonction enfin de de du cumul
de de d'événements ce matin pour pour
nous les sénateurs parce que je vois
quand même régulièrement revenir l'un ou
l'autre de ces sujet qui est parfois la
cohérence n'est pas explicite pour tout
le monde donc il y a des c'est très
piégeux pour VO dire les choses et je ne
peux pas m'empêcher donc j'en ai toute
la liberté de le faire d'observer avec
étonnement l'obsession sur l'écriture
inclusive voilà l'écriture inclusive est
une obsession
antigenre qui ne concerne pas l'écriture
inclusive et la manière dont on pratique
la langue française et on l'écrit mais
tout ce que ça signifie et tout ce qui
est vu et soupçonné derrière l'écriture
inclusive voilà c'était et ma question
je repose ma question que j'avais évoqué
tout à
l'heure le les l'extrême droite qui
vient de remporter une victoire
électorale en au Pays-Bas hier a-t-elle
inclus dans son programme des
propositions relatives à tous ces sujets
de genre et
d'IVG Anne Anne sis sénatrice de Paris
et futur présidente de la table ronde
suivante merci Madame la la présidente
de la Table Ronde non non c'est juste
une question et merci pour pour cette
table ronde qui est vraiment euh qui est
vraiment bien qui qui intervient à point
nommé dans les débats euh j'ai j'ai
quelques petites questions d'une part
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres pays qui ont
constitutionnalisé euh l'IVG
euh voilà petite question deuxème
question est-ce que cette charte vous
avez parlé de la de de l'idée de mettre
dans la Charte européenne des droits
fondamentaux
euh de la question de l'IVG est-ce que
c'est en cours est-ce que c'est c'est
une démarche qui d'une manière ou d'une
autre est déjà en train de prendre pied
ou place quelque part donc voilà c'est
mes mes
questions
courte mais
nécessaire et bien dans l'autre sens
peut-être il y a encore une question oh
pardon le sénateur solemon sénateur de
la Somme oui merci madame la Présidente
jeis une question vous parlez des sur
cette question là de tous les partis qui
sont en place est-ce que vous avez fait
une étude comparative des partis qui
sont en compétition oserais-je dire pour
la prise d'un pouvoir sur les pays tant
en France qu'en
[Musique]
Europe sur la question de la question de
l'entrrisme dans dans les
écoles notamment sur la la partie
éducation effectivement qu'on s'aperçoit
quand on étudie les mouvements
mouvements antidroit il s'attaque sur
différents sujets et Nil l'a dit euh
droit et santé sexuelle et et
reproductif la question des droits de
l'enfant notamment c'est pas aussi ce
biais làà qu'ils arrivent à à entrer sur
sur le sujet euh et aussi la question de
l'éducation complète à la sexualité euh
et c'est là où on les retrouve on les
retrouve également donc avortement
contraception mais aussi éducation
complète à la sexualité euh on a parlé
du cas de des ABCD de l'égalité en
France qui sont effectivement un cas
assez emblématique en la matière mais on
peut repenser là très récemment à la
Belgique où il y a eu justement une
levée de bouclier de la part d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs par rapport à
la question de l'éducation complète à la
sexualité et si on regarde aussi la
question aux États-Unis euh aujourd'hui
il y a un vrai sujet notamment dans dans
ce domaine-là et l'une des offensives
que les mouvements antidroits utilisent
c'est notamment pour atteindre les
droits des personnes trans notamment
notamment à travers par exemple les
toilettes en ne permettant pas la
l'indifférenciation dans dans dans les
toilettes par exemple mais aussi la
question tout simplement de l'éducation
complète à la sexualité l'un des points
d'entrée des mouvements antidroits c'est
ça ça a été dit hein que c'est apprendre
c'est apprendre aux enfants à la
maternelle la
masturbation ou de changer d'orientation
sexuel ou de de favoriser la transition
de genre par exemple ça c'est leurs
arguments en terme d'élément de langage
qu'on retrouve qu'on retrouve très
nettement et c'est ces tendances là
qu'on retrouve aux États-Unis on les
retrouve aussi également en France hein
où on voit notamment par exemple des
lectures pour les enfants de la part de
de collectif d'association pour les
personnes LGBT on voit une délevée de
bouclier par rapport à ça et la droite
et extrême droite euh s'infiltre
largement dans cette dans cette brèche-l
sur la convergence des des mouvements
religieux euh je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous Laurence Rossignol il
y a une convergence en fait de ces
acteursl qui se retrouvent en fait sur
le même sur le même agenda parce qu'en
réalité ils défendent la même chose ils
défendent une vision une vision
traditionnaliste conservatrice euh
hétéronormé de la famille du couple du
couple et de la famille et ce sont des
acteurs qu'on retrouve notamment dans
les instances internationales la
Fondation jeanurès est présente à la
commission sur le statut des femmes aux
nations- Unies et pour en avoir été
témoin dans dans un certain nombre
d'événements dont d'ailleurs des
événements qu'on avait coorganisé avec
vous lorsque vous étiez ministre de
l'Égalité quand on parle des questions
de droit à l'avortement ce que l'on
retrouve dans la salle aux Nations unies
dans les personnes présentes qui sont
issues de la société civile ce sont
principalement des personnes antiivg qui
sont présentes dans la dans la salle
principalement issues de structures
religieuses que ce soit des que ce soit
les associations catholiques
évangéliques principalement mais aussi
d'autres organisations en fait toute
religion toute religion confondue se se
retrouve enfin sur la question de
l'écriture inclusive aussi hein on le
disait sur les différents fronts qui qui
sont t attaqué l'écriture inclusive fait
partie d'un des fronts sur lesquels les
mouvements antidroits se se retrouvent
je trouve cet exemple assez illustratif
je parlais de Georgia Meloni donc qui
est donc la première
ministre en Italie elle réfute la
féminisation de sa dénomination elle
réfute la féminisation de son titre qui
est donc président du Conseil des
ministres en Italie donc ça montre bien
là aussi euh la façon dont il partage
très largement l'ensemble l'ensemble de
ces combats et enfin sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG à ma
connaissance à ma connaissance il y a
pas de il y a pas d'état en tout cas au
niveau européen qui ont
constitutionnalisé l'IVG par contre
évidemment que de l'inscrire dans dans
le marbre de la Constitution pour le cas
français permettrait de garantir
davantage davantage de droit pour les
femmes parce que ce qu'on a dit là
durant toute la table ronde c'est à quel
point ces droits-là ils sont réversibles
et ils sont réversibles d'autant plus
lorsque il y a des majorités et des
alternances politique et notamment on
voit on voit la la crainte que l'on peut
avoir par rapport à l'extrême droite et
sur l'inscription de la Charte des
droits fondamentaux des droits
fondamentaux par rapport au niveau au
niveau européen il y a un certain nombre
de résolutions qui ont été passés au
Parlement au Parlement européen une
résolution de mémoire et là Nil me
complètera sans doute une résolution qui
était passée en 2019 pour réaffirmer
réaffirmer le 2019 et 2022 de mémoire
aussi suite à la suite à la révocation
de l'arero virsus Wade et donc qui
montre bien la volonté des parlementaire
de garantir davantage de droit pour pour
pour pour l'IVG mais c'est il ne s'agit
pas d'une compétence de de l'Union que
d'agir sur ces questionsl et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raisonlà qu'elle
se cache derrière ça et qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment d'avancer en matière de défense
des droits sexuels et reproductifs
pardon j'ai été trop
long
jeanphès c'est à vous je sais pas ce que
ce que pour pour compléter alors oui
tout à fait sur la question de de
l'entrisme dans les écoles donc les
organisations dont je parlais family
watch international alliance defending
freedom qui est absolument instrumental
dans tout ce qui est en train de se
défaire en terme de droit à l'avortement
dans dans une majorité des États
américains ce sont des organisations qui
sont également locales américaines donc
en arizonie en Californie une des
grandes strat comme l'a dit Amandine
c'est bien sûr de de placer des
individus dans les associations de
parents
d'élèves pour s'acaparer bien sûr ces
questions des toilettes ou notamment du
sport et du sport
inclusif justement et d'utiliser ces ces
stratégies ou ces débat à outrance pour
avancer d'autres agendas mais on le voit
aussi avec une influence sur des
syndicats de parents d'élèves notamment
en Afrique de l'Ouest comme j'en parlais
comme j'en parlais tout à l'heure alors
bien sûr la question de des collutions
religieuse et la façon dont les dssr
lient des agendas euh aux Nations Unies
c'est c'est tout à fait fascinant comme
vous l'avez souligné madame rossinol à
titre d'exemple donc family watch
international dont je parle depuis tout
à l'heure est une organisation qui est
Mormon euh et cette organisation vient
de signer un un partenariat de
collaboration un Moyou des termes de
référence en fait avec l'Organisation de
Coopération islamique qui regroupe par
exemple 54 pays donc on trouve vraiment
euh quand on regarde les votes à Genève
à New York euh au sein des instances
internationales des alliances
stratégiques justement entant des pays
qui ont pas forcément euh des alliances
géopolitiques les plus les plus
évidentes euh euh la au au sommet
transatlantique dont je parlais la
semaine dernière il y avait la
Commission des Droits Humains marocain
qui a adressé l'assemblée avec un avocat
français euh sur la gestation pour
autruit euh on retrouve toutes sortes
bien sûr de euh d'alliance et de
collusion euh à ce à ce niveau-là et
c'est bien sûr pas juste le le le
christianisme qui est qui est en
question euh et ces partenariats
d'ailleurs vont avoir ont des impacts
euh euh notables au niveau de l'Union
Africaine et des législations euh
africaines particulièrement inquiétante
on voit euh vraiment ce terrain d'entrée
des organisations extrémistes mormons
chrétiennes américaines euh qui se voit
comme des grands alliés dans la lutte
contre l'avortement et contre les droits
homosexuels à l'international euh la
seule constitution au monde qui
reconnaît les droits à la santé sexuelle
et reproductive mais qui ne nomme pas
l'avortement spécifiquement c'est la
constitution de l'Afrique du Sud donc la
France ser effectivement pionnière en
tout cas à la
nommé si jamais cela cela passait je te
je te passe la
parole tenu de reprendre le micro et
bien écoutez c'est à VOUS Nils merci
beaucoup euh donc je vais aborder
certaines des questions euh d'abord sur
la diffusion au sein des milieux
religieux ce que ce qu'on peut constater
c'est que les idées antigenres ont
commencé dans les milieux catholiques
dans chez des penseurs catholiques
ensuite on migrait vers le Vatican donc
ce n'est pas le Vatican même qui qui les
a conçus de là ça s'est propagé dans
d'autres directions dans d'autres
mouvements chrétiens d'abord les
évangélistes protestants des Amériques
ensuite les protestants conservateurs en
Europe et ensuite vers le monde Orth oxe
donc maintenant la l'Église orthodoxe
russe est une des premières défenseurs
de de ces idées ensuite on voit aussi
des propagations vers les milieux
musulmans et là on on commence à même
voir que ça que que ces idées sont
accaparées par les milieux
hindou donc donc il y a une propagation
de ces de ces idées deuxièmement pour
les pour pour le milieu scolaire euh
juste pour juste pour compléter ce ce
qui a déjà été dit on voit certaines
façons que ces mouvements s'organisent
concernant les milieux scolaires d'abord
il y a l'organisation de groupe de
parents OK et ça on a vu ça dans surtout
en Russie dans les pays de l'Europe de
l'Est mais là je viens de me rendre
compte que monsieur zéour a créé un
genre de mouvement semblable ici en
France ok il y a aussi la promotion de
de comment est-ce qu'on dit homchooling
qu'on fait un collo a Sénat d'aille
l'éducation à la maison l'éducation à la
maison ok quelque chose qui est très
répandu aux États-Unis ça c'est quelque
chose qu'ils essaient de promouvoir en
Europe et il y a des il y a eu des
procès en Allemagne devant la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
revendiquer ce droit il y a aussi une
mobilisation contre l'éducation à la
sexualité par exemple en Belgique en
Belgique il ne se passait rien vraiment
je faisais partie de de de l'équipe de
cinq personnes commandé par la
secrétaire d'État l'égalité pour pour
rendre un rapport sur le mouvement
antiggenre en Belgique on était censé le
rendre au mois de septembre seembre on
avait presque rien trouvé sauf des
petits trucs par-ci par là et ensuite il
y a des incendies dans six écoles en
wallogie alors j'ai dû aller voir les
mes coéquipiers puis je leur dit bon
faut revoir notre travail là mais on na
rien vu venir et c'est c'est sorti tout
d'un coup comme ça ils se sont attaqués
à l'vas l'éducation à la vie
émotionnelle relationnelle et sexuelle
un petit c'est c'est pas grand-chose
dans les écoles francophones mais c'est
apparu comme ça et on voit là une
convergence des milieux une certaine
pensée catholique des milieux d'extrême
droite c'est eux qui ont fait les
incendie et ça a été repris par des
mouvements de masse issus
essentiellement des différentes
communautés musulmanes les Turques les
Kurdes les albanis et cetera c'est eux
qui ont manifesté dans dans les rues
donc il y a eu ceci euh l'éducation à la
sexualité est aussi apparu de nulle part
au Pays-Bas pays très progressiste et là
je vais terminer sur les Pays-Bas comme
me me l'a demandé madame
Rossignol au Pays-Bas il y a eu une
grande mobilisation quand contre les
contre l'éducation à la sexualité et qui
est apparu de nulle part mais qui a
vraiment perturbé l'échitier politique
au Pays-Bas et maintenant en
regardant en regardant les résultats des
élections parce que nous avons t tous lu
les les grande lignes que c'est
l'extrême droite qui qui a remporté les
élections de ce que je peux voir des
derniers résult at sur les 150 sièges
euh l'extrême droite de herfelders
aurait gagné 37 sièges donc il n'a pas
assez pour former un gouvernement tout
seul les Pays-Bas doivent former un
gouvernement en coalition et de ce que
je peux voir je je ne sais pas s'il a
suffisamment d'alliés politiques pour
former un gouvernement donc je crois que
je ne pense pas qu'il va devenir le
nouveau Premier ministre parmi au sein
des pays aux Pays-Bas il y a plusieurs
partis politiques qui sont antig-genre
il y a her builders lui il est plutôt
antiimmigration anti euh antimusulman et
cetera mais il y en a d'autres il y a le
parti pour euh pour la le euh le parti
pour la démocratie de Thierry baudé dans
leur programme politique ils avaient
demandé de couper les vivres à
l'équivalent du planque familiale
néerlandais et il de mener une croisade
contre le wokisme dans les universités
et puis aussi de euh de euh de regarder
les questions de d'éducation à la
sexualité donc ça c'était le le parti de
Thierry baudé et il y a aussi deux
partis politiques euh euh protestants de
l'église protestante néerlandaise très
traditionnalistes et ils ont été au
pouvoir pendant régulièrement ces
dernières décennies et c'est ce sont ces
partis politiques et les ONG liés à ce
parti politique qui ont pu recevoir des
fonds pendant un certain temps pour
organiser des centres de désinformation
pour les femmes concernant leur
grossesse euh et donc et ça c'était
vraiment payé par l'État à un certain
moment ils avaient 13 centres de
désinformation sur le territoire
néerlandais les vivres ont uniquement
été coupés il y a quelques années et
donc ces mouvements ont leur accès au
monde politique suffisamment pour
pouvoir toucher des fonds et euh mettre
en mettre en pratique donc ce que ça va
donner aux Pays-Bas maintenant je ne
sais pas mais il y aura une forme
d'antigenre au sein du gouvernement
néerlandais faudra voir lequel
c'est écz je vous remercie tous les
trois pour tout toutes vos compétences
votre expertise votre connaissance et
votre engagement quand même sur ces
sujets voilà parce que c'est on ne
traite pas ces sujets sans y être engagé
et après la description un peu
accablante que vous venez de nous faire
de l'état du monde on va finir cette
matinée avec une table ronde positive
voilà qui va nous parler nous qui va
évoquer le travail des ONG
Prochoix dans les différents pays où
elles interviennent et c'est Anne sis
sénatrice de Paris qui va me remplacer à
cette place et à cette
tribune
ils sont plus que
deux c'est ce qu'on a
et bien maintenant que tout le monde est
en place apparemment il y a quelqu'un
qui doit être en visio c'est ça qui est
qui se connecte qui est en train de se
connecter
qui depuis Dakar et donc Ann sis je vous
laisse la
parole merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente et chers collègues comme l'a
dit Laurence rousinal tout à l'heure en
fait on essaie de finir sur une tonalité
positive je pense qu'on va y arriver et
sur en tout cas sinon positive en tout
cas combative pour que une
tonalité qui permette l'accent sur des
actions concrètes qui soit menées par
des nombreuses associations et
organisations qui existent hein
mondialement enfin je veux dire on a on
a vu qu' existait des organisations et
et qui qui vraiment enfraignent en fait
cette liberté d'accès à l'IVG et et au
genre et d'ailleurs à toutes les
questions de genre et l'évolution du
genre dans le monde mais il y a aussi
quand même une lutte organisée et bien
organisée et mieux organisée qui va
falloir de mieux en mieux organiser
certainement et c'est pour ça qu'on
organise ce type de table ronde pour
pouvoir nous-même aussi voir ce qui
peut-être ce qui manque et comment on
peut contribuer à ces questionsl pour
permettre de pouvoir renforcer les
droits des femmes dans les différents
pays en particulier dans ceux dont on
qu'on a pu évoquer qui sont
particulièrement l'objet de restrictions
d'interdits et qui peuvent conduire non
seulement à un problème de santé et un
amendissement de la santé des femmes et
de leur liberté mais aussi parfois à la
mort hein parce que en fait c'est un
petit peu ce qui a été dit c'est que ces
questions-là sont aussi des questions de
vie ou de mort alors face à des des
légistrations tion restrictive et à des
barrières sociales économiques et
culturelles face aussi à des groupes au
groupes d'acteurs que vous avez pu
décrire ces structures se mobilisent
pour fournir des informations
essentielles sur les droits reproductifs
faciliter l'accès à des services
d'avortement sûr et soutenir les femmes
avant pendant et après l'avortement al
il est essentiel de voir comment on peut
faire connaître ces structures comment
on peut soutenir ces organisations au
niveau où nous sommes d'autant que leurs
membres se mettent parfois leur sécurité
en jeu pour défendre le droit des femmes
à l'avortement alors nous allons
entendre ce matin des témoignage de
trois organisations qui agissent sur le
terrain et qui pourront nous euh aider à
comprendre ce qu'il se passe et à faire
part à la fois des difficultés qu'elle
rencontre mais aussi des solutions
qu'elle met en œuvre je souhaite ainsi
la bienvenue à Sandrine Simon qui est
directrice de la santé et du plaidoyer
chez Médecins du Monde la présidente de
Médecins du Monde docteur Florence régal
avait signé l'année dernière une tribune
dans Le Monde mettant en garde face aux
menaces qui pèse sur les droits et la
santé des femmes et appelant à désobéir
à des lois injustes et dangereuses
madame Simon témoignera des difficultés
rencontré par les équipe de médecins du
Monde et des actions que cellees-ci
mènent pour soutenir le droit à toute
personne d'accéder à une IVG légale et
sans risque à la fois par des services
de santé sur le terrain et par des
actions de plaidoyer à l'international
nejjma ben CR qui sera en visio j'espère
qu'elle va pouvoir se connecter qui est
directrice régionale d'Afrique centrale
et Afrique de l'Ouest francophone chez
DKT international organisation privée à
but non lucratif spécialisé dans la
santé reproductive elle évoquera des
solutions possibles pour offrir des
méthodes d'avortement sécurisé et des
des pilules abortibles dans des pays où
la réglementation est restrictive elle
intervient aujourd'hui par
visioconférence donc depuis D car
Pauline Diaz
enfin spécialiste des droits sexuels et
reproductifs et d'innovation y santé
directrice de safe to
choose.org organisation basée en Afrique
et qui fournit des conseils en ligne aux
femmes souhaitant accéder à des
informations et des services
d'avortement sûr dans le monde merci
beaucoup à tous bien sûr de votre
participation ce matin et pour votre
engagement il va sans dire que on a
notre colloque a une visée Mobil
isatrice et nous espérons qu'en dressant
un panorama mondial des restrictions au
droit et acccès à l'avortement il est
l'occasion pour nous de réfléchir à la
conjonction de contextes nationaux et
d'une conjoncture
internationale il va s'en dire et c'est
ce qui a été un peu le constat qui a été
fait juste avant un un vent mauvais
souffle sur les droits des femmes pas
seulement comme on a pu le voir aux
États-Unis ou dans d'autres pays mais en
Europe même et même j'allais dire un
petit peu plus encore cailleur j'espère
que ce col va être un appel à l'action à
la suité mondiale je je pense que tous
et toutes ici nous le souhaitons en tout
cas et une question me tient à cœur
comment créer des réseaux des pratiques
et des actions de plaéidoyer qui aideent
les femmes quel que soit le pays dans
lequel le hasard les a fait naître donc
je je vais vous ne pas je vous
reparlerai peut-être après vous poser
des questions mais en tout cas je vais
d'abord sans plus tarder donner la
parole à Sandrine Simon de Médecin du
Monde
merci merci beaucoup pour
l'invitation c'est évidemment un plaisir
d'être ici pour parler de de ces enjeux
dont nous faisons face au quotidien sur
sur nos différents terrains
d'intervention on a beaucoup parlé du du
droit ce matin et c'est bien légitime et
c'est essentiel mais je voudrais
introduire mon propos à ralan que
l'avortement et et d'abord un soin de
centré un soin de santé primaire et un
enjeu de santé publique bon évidemment
en tant que ONG médicale de ma
perspective c'est un peu normal de
l'aborder comme ça mais ça me semble
essenciel aussi de de de se rappeler que
avant tout c'est la santé des femmes euh
qui est en jeu on a parlé de quelques
chiffres ce matin mais peut-être juste
pour rappel donc se redire qu'il y a
quand même une femme qui meurt toutes
les 9 minutes dans le monde euh suite à
un avortement réalisé dans de mauvaises
conditions mais aussi on a beaucoup
parlé des décès mais peut-être pas des
des conséquences et des complications
qui peuvent exister il y a 7 millions de
femmes par exemple par an qui sont
hospitalisés euh à la suite euh des
conséquences d'un avortement pratiqué
dans de dans de mauvaises dans de
mauvaises conditions c'est c'est l'OMS
qui nous rappelle qui nous rappelle ces
chiffres euh on l'a déjà dit euh ce
matin mais ce qui est important de se
dire c'est que bah une personne qui
souhaite avorter elle avortera je pense
que c'est voilà c'est quelque chose
qu'on qu'on se redit tous euh la
différence c'est est-ce qu'elle va le
faire de manière sécurisée ou non euh je
je me rappelle de de mon expérience sur
le terrain au Mozambique où j'ai eu à
traiter euh plusieurs femmes qui qui
sont qui sont venus dans des états de
septicémie grave parce que
malheureusement excusez-moi d'utiliser
ces termes mais elle c'était introduit
toutes sortes de produits dans le vagin
pour pouvoir arrêter une grossesse
qu'elle ne pouvait pas mener à terme à
ce à ce moment de de leur vie donc c'est
vraiment des des choix importants donc
au au dépit de leur de leur santé les
femmes peuvent recourir à à des des
gestes assez extrêmes euh et puis aussi
se dire que finalement et je reparle de
droit par pardon mais les lois
antiavortement sont des lois prof
profondément
inégalitaires puisque finalement une
femme qui a les moyens va toujours
trouver une solution sécurisé d'avoir
accès à l'avortement mais c'est souvent
bien les personnes les plus précaires
qui vont recueillir à des moyens
dangereux pour leur santé ou pour leur
vie et je prends pour exemple un projet
que nous avons eu en Uruguay une dizaine
d'années c'était assez stupéfiant pardon
de constater qu'il y avait certains
praticiens euh qui finalement était
objecteur de conscience dans le système
public mais qui n'avait pas de problème
à pratiquer l'avortement dans le système
privé donc c'est aussi voilà c'est ces
situations qu'on rencontre sur le
terrain et puis on l'a déjà évoqué mais
légaliser l'avortement finalement n'est
pas incitatif mais réduit les avortement
non sécurisé et bien souvent et mais
vous on l'évoquit beaucoup sur la table
ronde précédente euh les politiques qui
permettent l'accès à l'avortement sont
accompagnés de politiques dssr plus
global dans un continuum de soins et de
service en santé sexuelle et
reproductive et et permettent un
meilleur accès à la planification
familiale à l'éducation sexuelle à la à
la sexualité et finalement réduisent le
nombre d'avortement bien sûr il y en a
toujours euh euh des femmes qui en ont
qui en ont besoin euh mais finalement ça
assez hypocrite de de voilà de de se
dire que euh légaliser l'avortement va
inciter à plus plus d'avortement euh et
l'OMS reconnaît euh bien cet enjeu de de
de santé publique et a inscrit dans ses
recommandations pour la santé mondiale
l'avortement comme un soin de santé
primaire il préconise la
décriminalisation complète de
l'avortement la disponibilité de
l'avortement à la demande de la femme
sans quelconque
autorisation la protection deaccès à
l'avortement contre les obstacles créés
par la clause de conscience et la
promotion d'approche aussi d'autogestion
c'est-à-dire par exemple l'autoprise en
charge des processus d'avortement
médicamenteux je voudrais aussi faire un
petit focus sur les contextes de crise
qui sont aussi des contextes extrêmement
importants où où l'accès à l'avortement
est aussi un soin essentiel pour les
femmes on constate bien souvent sur nos
terrains d'intervention et
malheureusement ils sont beaucoup en
contexte de crise en ce moment les
conséquences sur la santé sur la vie des
femmes que peuvent avoir des ruptures
contraceptive par exemple ou le nonaccès
avortement notamment dans des contextes
et à l'approche de la Journée
internationale de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes dans des
contextes où les où les violences
sexuelles sont encore plus plus accru
mais donc permettez-moi de d'expliquer
peut-être un peu plus en détail
l'approche de Médecin du Monde sur le
terrain finalement on a un mode d'action
dans dans une quinzaine de de pays dans
le monde sur les droits sexuels et
reproductifs autour de trois piliers euh
tout d'abord de permettre bah du coup
l'accès aux soins des personnes et donc
de renforcer l'offre de soins en santé
sexuelle et reproductive y compris donc
l'accès à l'avortement sécurisé pour les
femmes une approche communautaire donc
au plus près des population pour bien
comprendre finalement les déterminants
les enjeux et les obstacles qui font que
les femmes n'accèdent pas au service de
santé même quand ce serait possible
selon la loi et du plédoyer pour
accompagner finalement les sociétés
civiles qui veulent qui veulent que leur
droit soit soit respectés et
inscritcr éc dans la loi et bien sûr
donc pour tout ça on travaille
énormément en partenariat et ce qui est
très important pour nous c'est de
soutenir les initiative local les
acteurs locaux et vous le disiez ils
sont nombreux et effectivement en tant
que voilà ONG médical qui œuvre à à
l'international on a parfois plus de
facbilité facilité pardon à intervenir
on prend peut-être moins de risque que
des acteurs locaux qui peuvent avoir des
risques importants peu de financement
peu de peu de capacité d'action donc
notre rôle est vraiment vraiment de de
pouvoir aussi les reforcer et parfois de
leur donner accès au sphères de pouvoir
qui c'est un peu une contradiction mais
c'est parfois plus facile pour nous
d'avoir accès aux sphères de pouvoir
dans les pays où nous intervenons que
les organisations locales elles-mêmes
donc on essaie finalement de pouvoir
créer une forme d'organisation de ces
acteurs locaux puisque pour qu'elles
puissent avoir exprimer
finalement leur souhait dans les sphères
de pouvoir de leur pays donc peut-être
et puis ce que je voulais dire aussi
c'est qu'on parlait beaucoup des des
blocages mais les blocages ils sont
parfois internes et ça fait plus de 10
ans que médecin du monde s'est affirmé
engagé pour le pour le droit à
l'avortement finalement on s'est rendu
compte au fil des années que c'était pas
si simple pour nous non plus d'offrir un
soin complet à l'avortement dans les
pays et notamment on a fait un travail
un peu d' d'introspection pardon pour
voir quels étaient les blocages internes
qui faisaient que l'accès à l'avorte
enfin qu'on ne fournissait pas et qu'on
ne répondait pas aux besoins des femmes
partout dans l'ensemble de nos pays
d'interv inention les besoins ils sont
multiples je vais enfin les pardon les
blocages sont multiples et je vais peut
pas y revenir mais c'est pour ça aussi
que l'année prochaine l'année dernière
pardon nous avons renouvelé nos
engagements internes et externes sur sur
ce droit fondamental et je pense que
c'est aussi important régulièrement de
renouveler ses engagements et de pas
rester sur des acquis donc oui bon on
l'a on l'a mis dans nos positionnements
donc il y a pas de problème on va le
faire mais ça ne suffit pas c'est un peu
comme le nos gouvernement ça ne suffit
pas la loi c'est comment on le met en
pratique complètement et c'est vrai pour
chacun chacun d'entre nous et et en tant
qu'acteur et ça passe aussi par
l'accompagnement des équipes la
sensibilisation la formation évidemment
et donc peut-être rapidement sur ces
trois piliers donc sur la sur sur le
pilier plutôt autour de l'offre de soins
évidemment on travaille avec les
systèmes de de santé locaux dans les
pays où nous intervenons et peut-être
une première étape c'est c'est de
permettre et d'accompagner les systèmes
de santé pour qu'il fassent tout ce qui
est possible dans le cadre de la loi et
je me rappelle un un atelier qu'on avait
eu au Burkina il y a il y a quelques
années où finalement c'est un juriste
burkinabé qui est venu parler à nos
équipes et aux professionnels de santé
nationaux avec lesquels on travaillait
pour leur dire mais vous dites que vous
êtes dans l'illégalité si vous pratiquez
l'avortement mais en fait c'est vous qui
êtes dans l'illégalité si vous ne
permettez pas aux femmes d'avoir accès à
l'avortement puisque la loi le permet au
moins dans certaines conditions donc
c'était aussi intéressant d'avoir un peu
peu un peu ce rappel et de se dire
comment dans les systèmes de santé on on
on permet de faire tout qui est possible
dans le cadre de la loi et au moins
partout dans le monde les soins
post-avortement sont possibles et donc
de former les professionnels de santé au
soins post-avortement c'est une première
étape essentielle et quand on sait faire
des soins postavortement on sait aussi
faire un avortement donc après chaque
professionnel de santé en conscience euh
agira comme voilà comme il pense le
mieux pour la patiente qu'il a qu'il a
en face de lui euh donc c'est vraiment
travailler permettre donc renforcer
l'accès aux médicaments au
matériel améliorer la formation
évidemment comme pour tout pour toutous
soins de santé finalement on travaille
sur l'avortement comme pour tout accès
aux soins de de de santé et comme je
disais on travaille aussi beaucoup au
niveau communautaire on appui aux
acteurs par exemple en République
démocratique du Congo on appuie une
organisation locale qui s'appelle
afiaamama qui pratiquait déjà de des
avortements qui accompagnaient les
femmes au niveau communautaire mais
voilà on a renforcé leurs compétences on
leur a permis d'avoir accès du
misoprostol de meilleure qualité comment
on crée aussi un réseau de de pharmacie
sûre euh dans les dans les pays où on
sait que le misise au prostol par
exemple et la la M priston c'est parfois
un peu plus difficile à obtenir mais en
tout cas la mise au prostol est quand
même facilement accessible dans beaucoup
de pharmacies du monde mais comment on
s'assure que ce réseau se rassure et que
les pharmaciens sont en capacité de
donner la bonne information aux femmes
donc c'est c'est c'est finalement des
petits pas que l'on fait dans les pays
en en connaissant bien les contextes
pour adapter nos actions aux réalités et
aux acteurs en présence qui permettent
finalement dans la
confidentialité de répondre aux besoins
des aux besoins des personnes et de leur
donner la bonne information on a
beaucoup parlé de désinformation donc ça
c'est vraiment un enjeu essentiel de
pouvoir donner la la bonne information
aux personnes et encore une fois de leur
dire si vous avez un souci à la maison
par exemple quand vous pratiquer un
autoavortement les soins postavortement
sont inscrits partout et vous pouvez
aller dans le système de santé sans
crainte en tout cas normalement tout
professionnel de santé devrait traiter
euh enfin devrait pouvoir réaliser un
soin postavortement dans de bonnes
conditions sans questionner les femmes
qui viennent euh pour cela euh je vais
pas passer vite sur la question de
l'information aux femmes parce que je
pense mes collègues en parleront plus
largement et peut-être pour finir donc
vous dire qu'effectivement on travaille
aussi sur le levier du du plaédoyer
notre pliddoyer étant construit vraiment
à partir de la réalité de terrain que
l'on que l'on rencontre euh et l'enjeu
est de est de faire prendre conscience
finalement de de la réalité euh pour les
femmes mais pour les personnes
finalement hein parce que derrière les
femmes c'est parfois aussi des des des
familles il faut pas se dire non plus
que les femmes sont toujours seul à
prendre la décision c'est parfois des
des choix de couple aussi pas toujours
mais ça peut le ça peut l'être donc
comment euh on permet de visibiliser euh
cette cette réalité de terrain et de la
faire entendre dans les sphères de
décision c'est vraiment ça le l'enjeu on
va dire un petit peu premier de notre
décision et de faire en sorte que les
acteurs au plus proches des des
populations des femmes puissent être
entendu dans ces sphères de décision
c'est un peu toute la démarche de
plédoyer qu'on essaie de mettre en œuvre
dans les pays en où on intervient bien
sûr en coalition hein parce que comme
les antichois ben on essaie d'être en
coalition parce que à plusieurs on est
on est plus fort évidemment et on peut
se faire entendre plus plus facilement
euh mais donc c'est vraiment tout
l'enjeu et par exemple parfois on met en
place des recherches opérationnelles sur
nos terrain d'intervention pour pouvoir
mieux visibiliser rendre visible tous
ces blocages tous ces déterminants qui
font que le l'accès il est limité et
aussi toute la réalité des personnes euh
qui qui font qu'à un moment ou donné de
leur vie elles ont besoin d'avoir
recours à un avortement euh et que ce
n'est pas finalement quelque chose de
marginal comm on peut l'entendre parfois
mais c'est une réalité forte qui peut
amener à des conséquences comme on l'a
évoqué toutes ces toute cette matinée
euh bah catastrophique pour la santé ou
la vie des femmes mais au-delà de la vie
des femmes c'est finalement la vie des
communautés parce que une femme qui
meurt c'est tout un système social qui
se délite aussi et qui peut avoir des
impacts
euh dramatiques euh sur sur une société
et sur une sur une communauté donc voilà
je peut-être je m'arrêterai là
évidemment avec Ave avec plaisir pour
répondre à vos questions et peut-être
juste pour conclure euh parce qu'on
l'évoquait de depuis ce matin et ça me
ça me paraît important dans cet instant
sur cette histoire de cons
constitutionnalisation du droit à
l'avortement je pense comment on l'a vu
sur ce qui s'est passé aux États-Unis
qui a eu un impact voilà effroyable si
la France faisait ce paslà je pense que
ça enverrait un signal fort de soutien
aux citoyens et citoyennes qui se
battent pour défendre le droit à
l'avortement euh notamment dans les pays
où ce droit est interdit ou restreint et
puis ce soutien je pense qu'on en a tous
et toutes besoin
merci merci beaucoup j'ai est-ce que il
y a quelques questions qui
s'adresse faire tout à la fin peut-être
à la fin préférez qu'on pour qu'on aille
un petit peu plus vite c'est ça voilà je
comprends je comprends bon donc je en
tout cas moi je nurai une mais je je la
reporte je vous propose donc si oui je
vois qu'elle est arrivée nejjma Benzekri
donc qui est directrice du bureau
régional d'Afrique de l'Ouest et central
francophone de l'ONG DKT international
je vous donne la
parole bienvenue merci bonjour à tous
j'espère que vous m'entendez
bien
alors déjà merci de m'avoir permis de
participer à cette table ronde notamment
sur ce sujet qui mais'est très important
aujourd'hui je représente donc decaté
international qui est une organisation à
but non lucratif qui a été créée en
89 et qui est une organisation de
marketing social donc notre mission
principale est d'offrir au couple des
options abordables et sûr en terme de
planification familiale de prévention du
viage sida et aussi bien entendu dans
l'avortement sécurisé nous sommes un des
premiers distributeurs mondials de
méthodes de contraception de produit et
d'accès à l'avortement sécurisé et en
particulier dans les pays émergents euh
puisque nous opérons dans 35 pays sud et
avec un focus dans le secteur privé
c'est-à-dire la distribution de ces
méthodes dans les pharmacies
essentiellement mais aussi clinique et
officin euh voilà donc moi je suis basée
au Sénégal à Dakar je couvre un
programme Afrique de l'Ouest et central
francophone donc c'est à peu près 13
pays d'Afrique sub-saharienne où euh
l'accès à la santé de la reproduction
reste un enjeu majeur aujourd'hui en
terme de santé publique et bien entendu
l'accès à l'avortement sécurisé
puisqueaujourd'hui donc la législation
en Afrique francophone est très
restrictive donc on a à peu près 92 %
des femmes de 15 à 49 ans qui habitent
dans des pays où la juridiction est
fortement modérément limité et euh dans
la zone dans laquelle nous opérons nous
avons uniquement le Bénin aujourd'hui
qui autorise l'accès à l'avortement
sécurisé ce depuis fin 2021 un droit qui
reste encore fragile dans ce pays
puisqu'il est très peu exécuté par les
prestataires de santé notamment pour des
raisons euh religieuses et de
stymatisation donc en
terme de proportion enfin un petit peu
de données aujourd'hui la région
représente la plus grande proportion
estimée d'avortement non sécurisés dans
le monde euh comme je disais du fait de
sa restriction légale de sa
stigmatisation et on représente
également le plus haut taux de de
mortalité qui sont liées à l'avortement
donc on compte à peu près 185 décès
maternels pour 100000 avortements c'est
un taux qui reste en faible baisse et je
pense que c'est important de le noter
notamment depuis les années 2000 et
notamment grâce aux divers euh efforts
qui sont faits euh par les organisations
société civile et euh certains
ministères euh donc je pense que c'est
important de de de surligner en tout cas
c impact et ces avancé euh pour le droit
des femmes dans la région d'Afrique
sub-saharienne donc en 2003 l'Union
africaine a adopté un protocole qui
s'appelle le Protocole de
Maputo un protocole qui amène les États
signataires à garantir les droits des
femmes notamment le droit de participer
au processus politique l'égalité sociale
et politique avec les hommes et une
autonomie améliorée dans leur décision
en matière de santé donc l'article 14 de
ce protocole stipule que l'avortement
doit être autorisé pour sauver la vie
d'une femme et préserver sa santé
physique ou mentale ainsi qu'en cas de
viol d'inceste ou de malformation fétal
grave donc depuis lors on a à peu près
se pays subsahariens qui ont réformé
leur législation pour satisfaire et en
dans un cas celui du Bénin dépasser ces
critères minimaux mais il reste encore
de nombreux pays qui ont signé mais pas
encore ratifié ce protocole euh
notamment le Sénégal pays dans lequel je
vis et notre bureau régional est basé un
pays où l'avortement est totalement
interdit euh ne serait-ce qu'en cas de
santé de la femme
donc le rôle de décaté international euh
dans dans cet environnement et ce
contexte qui est peu favorable euh
notamment sur ce sujet euh c'est de
mettre à disposition donc des
populations euh des Médicam d'avortement
sécurisé mais aussi de former les
prestataires de santé dans les soins
post-avortement et donc euh parmi ces
options ces médicaments nous avons deux
types qui ont été tantôt cités euh dans
la dans la présentation euh juste avant
moi donc nous avons le comipa qui est un
mélange de mph priston et de
moprostol le combi PAC la seule et
unique indication aujourd'hui donc c'est
l'interruption de grossesse volontaire
médicalisé et nous avons le misoprostol
dont
euh dont la première indication
est la prévention de l'hémorragie
postpartum donc le moprostol aujourd'hui
est beaucoup plus facile et beaucoup
plus disponible euh du utilisation dans
les pays mais sachez que depuis 2017
nous avons réussi des cat international
à enregistrer le combiac dans plusieurs
pays donc dans 10 pays d'Afrique de
l'Ouest et
central des pays où ce produit
n'existait pas où il y avait un un
manque de connaissance accru au Sénégal
par exemple comme je disais juste avant
nous distribuons le miseoprostol ce qui
nous permet en tout cas d'assurer
une comment dire une méthode disponible
pour
l'autoavortement même si c'est fortement
encadré en pharmacie et qu'il y a de
plus en plus de rejets de servir les
populations malgré les prescriptions qui
sont présentées donc ormis le challenge
d'opérer dans des environnements
juridiques qui sont contraignants nous
avons dû faire face à une quasi
inexistence de l'utilisation des
produits comme je disais et un manque de
connaissance accru c'est pourquoi en
2018 on a créé donc un programme de
formation de sages-femmes pour les
sages-femmes et ce programme nous a
permis de former plus de 50000
prestataires de santé depuis lors et
donc d'améliorer les connaissances
d'utilisation du combiipac à plus large
échelle et des produits utilisés dans le
cadre de l'avortement sécurisé puisqu'il
n'y a pas uniquement les pilules
abortives il existe également donc une
méthode donc un kit d'aspiration
manuelle intrautérin qui est largement
utilisé en cas de fausse couche et disp
disponible dans ces
pays donc nous avons également une
équipe sur le terrain qui promeut
l'utilisation de ces différentes
méthodes auprès des des gynécologues
donc notre C première c'est vraiment les
prestataires de santé dans le secteur
privé et public et nous ajouissons donc
en collaboration et partenariat avec les
associations de gynécologues dans
certains pays sagfemm euh et un de
notres objectif est d'intégrer dans les
cursus universitaires de de ces
formations euh des modules euh sur
l'utilisation de ces produits et euh à
minima euh d'aborder ce sujet euh qui
est très peu abordé aujourd'hui euh lors
d'un cursus de formation sage-femme et
gynécologie en ce qui concerne les
actions auprès des populations qui
restent primordiales et critiques euh
notre stratégie euh est vraiment de se
concentrer sur la lutte euh de la
stigmatisation et notamment sensibiliser
les femmes au risque de l'avortement
clandestin puisque on sait très bien que
même si cette av enfin l'avortement
aujourd'hui est interdit dans ces pays
euh de nombreuses femmes ont recours à
de méthodes clandestine qui expos en
fait leur vie et d'où ce taux de matité
de mortalité qui est très élevé dans
notre
région donc nous créons des campagnes
éducatives avec les femmes et pour les
femmes et notamment les prestataires de
santé euh pour les sensibiliser aux
options d'avortement sans risque et en
particulier donc dans les zones les plus
reculées les zones pauvre et rural donc
on a mis en place un système euh de
paire donc on a des des jeunes femmes
euh qui vont parler et sensibiliser les
femmes dans les villages dans les pays
et qui sont aujourd'hui des points
focaux pour tout ce qui est santé euh de
la reproduction euh ce qui nous permet
d'avoir une présence au niveau national
hormis les canaux de sensibilisation
connus qui sont radio donc réseaux
sociaux euh
et en principal internet donc grâce à
ces différentes actions au niveau
mondial des Kat en 2022 a permis
d'éviter 9 millions d'avortements donc
c'est ce qui a été comptabilisé et nous
avons à peu près vendu 6 millions de
COMBIPACK euh donc ça c'est vraiment à
l'échelle globale en Afrique de l'Ouest
donc on cumule à peu près 500000 ventes
de combiipack depuis qu'on l'a
enregistré mais euh voilà 5 ans que nous
avons les autorisations de m sur le
marché et on se confronte à un réel
problème de renouvellement de ces
autorisations de mise sur le marché donc
on sent vraiment qu'il y a des
mouvements
antiroit et beaucoup de de contraintes à
à renouveler en fait ces AMM et sans ces
AMM là nous ne pourrons continuer la
distribution du combiipac euh ce qui est
un réel challenge aujourd'hui
en terme d'objectif et perspective donc
on a l'objectif d'accroître le nombre de
formation et notre présence au niveau
nationaux notamment national pardon au
niveau de certains pays donc où la
stabilité politique et sécuritaire et
aussi un challenge mais on souhaite
également donc
lancer une pilule abortive un combipa
qui a été préqualifié par
l'OMS et espérons que nous pourrons être
listés comme médic essentiels dans
certains pays notamment le Bénin euh
sachant que les médicaments essentiels
sont des médicaments qui sont mis à
disposition des populations par l'État
dans les divers centres de santé euh
donc voilà c'est c'est un de notres
objectifs et que généralement ces
produits qui sont préqualifiés par l'OMS
sont généralement mieux appréciés au
niveau du secteur public et bénéficie
d'un système rapide d'enregistrement je
pense qu'il est important de notifier
que aujourd'hui pour démarrer la
commercialisation et la distribution euh
d'un médicament il faut avant tout
l'enregistrer donc auprès des directions
pharmaceutiques locales et euh ce
process peut prendre jusqu'à 2 ans donc
qui a un impact considérable puisque en
attendant ben le besoin est toujours
présent et euh les femmes ont recours
comme on disait à euh ces avortements
clandestins donc on a décidé aussi
d'accroître notre champ d'action et
d'initier des partenariats avec
différentes organisations euh notamment
des organisations féministes de la
région qui sont de plus en plus présent
et qui portent leur voix euh comme les
pays en Côte d'Ivoire Burkina Bénin euh
et bien entendu de euh promouvoir donc
l'autogestion
euh grâce enfin dans des pays comme le
Bénin mais aussi grâce à d'autres
systèmes en ligne euh notamment ce qui
va être présenté par ma collègue
paulindia juste après le counselling
online des Contact Center qui permettent
aux femmes d'accéder à une
information en temps réel et
gratuitement et de pouvoir récupérer
certaines prescriptions au niveau de
certains prestataires de santé pour
pouvoir ensuite effectuer cette
manipulation donc cet avortement
sécurisé à la maison ou dans un endroit
où elle se sent en sécurité pardon de de
vous Inter mais il va falloir juste que
tout le monde puisse parler parce qu'on
doit finir 11h30 donc ce que je vous
propose c'est que notre dernière
intervenante prenne la parole et puis
après vous répondrez aux questions bien
entendu désolé de vous interrompre comme
ça mais on a un un temps un petit peu
contraint je vous remercie beaucoup en
tout cas Pauline Diaz je vous laisse la
parole
merci j'attends juste un PowerPoint en
tout cas bonjour à toutes et à tous
merci de nous avoir invité
je vais juste le temps que le powerpoint
se mette en place juste une petite
rectification safe to choose c'est une
plateforme
internationale qui donne des
informations sur les services d'IVG
sécurisés et qui Orient vers des
professionnels de santé sur le terrain
j'étais personnellement basée en Afrique
pendant presque 10 ans mais aujourd'hui
je je suis en france et je dirige la
plateforme depuis la France et tout
comme toute l'équipe de save to choose
tout le monde est basé à distance dans
plus de 20
pays donc save to choose qu'est-ce que
c'est tout d'abord c'est un site
internet qui est traduit dans plus de 10
langues et qui donne des informations
sur toutes les méthodes d'avortement
sécurisé que ce soit l'avortement
médicamenteux par aspiration
chirurgicale ou les soins
post-avortement avec différents contenus
et format de diffusion des témoignages
des blogs des des vidéos de protocole
par exemple et qui permet la connexion
avec des conseillères une équipe de
conseillères qui répond par chat ou par
email à toutes les questions euh que les
personnes enceintes de partout dans le
monde pourraient avoir sur l'avortement
ça a été lancé en 2015 et depuis 2015 on
a reçu plus de 17 millions de visites
sur le site du monde entier et on a pu
soutenir en direct plus de 250000
personnes donc en direct c'est par chat
ou par email et faire des orientations à
des professionnels de santé sur le
terrain à plus de 54000 personnes la
vraie force de safe to choose c'est
l'équipe de conseillères 10 conseillères
qui sont basés dans 10 pays différents
qui parle plus de 10 langues qui
répondent toute la journée à des
questions sur l'avortement sécurisé et
qui orientent vers des professionnels de
santé si besoin ça permet vraiment euh
déjà de couvrir une une étendue horaire
et des fuseaux horaires parce qu'elles
sont basé dans dans plusieurs physos
horaires mais aussi ça permet de
répondre à ces personnes dans leur
langue natale avec la sensibilité de de
la
culture alors ça c'est la carte du
Center for reproductive rights bien sûr
on voit que l'hémisphère Sud Est est
bien plus restrictif légalement c'est
principalement là où on travaille avec
safe to choose même si je vous ai mis le
le top 10 des des pays qui nous
contactent on a les États-Unis bien sûr
dedans alors surtout depuis ce qui s'est
passé en 2022
h mais voilà le le le cœur du métier
c'est de travailler dans les pays où
l'avortement n'est pas accessible ou en
tout cas restreint si quelqu'un nous
contacte depuis la France par exemple on
va directement les réorienter vers le
familial mais voilà pour les États-Unis
par exemple parce que c'était un sujet
ce matin on travaille avec des ONG aux
États-Unis mais aussi par exemple au
Mexique qui permettent d'envoyer les
pilules aux
Américaines alors il y a trois cas eu
les chiffres ont été un petit peu
mélangés mais il y a il y a trois cas
vraiment sur lesquels on trois
situations dans lesquelles on soutient
les personnes enceintes la première qui
est la majorité des cas les personnes
qui nous contactent ont déjà les pilul
sportive avec elle donc ensemble on avec
les conseillères on discute pour savoir
si déjà il n a pas de contre-indication
médicale donc on a une doctoresse dans
l'équipe qui vérifie ça mais aussi on va
vérifier si les pilules elles sont de
bonne qualité si elles sont pas périmées
et si les protocoles qui ont peut-être
déjà été utilisés ont été les bons ou en
tout cas conseiller les personnes par
chat ou par email dans dans
l'utilisation de ces pilules pour un
avortement médicamenteux
autogéré voilà je je veux pas rappeler
enfin les bénéfices vraiment de
l'avortement médicamenteux ça ça permet
de d'effacer quand même des barrières de
de de localisation de budget de
choix et c'est un vrai avantage de
pouvoir avoir cette cette méthode là
dans les deuxièmes cas on va référer
réorienter vers des professionnels de
santé sur le terrain que ce soit pour un
avortement médicamenteux parce que ces
personnesl n'auraient pas l'épiluse
abortive ou parce que elle préfère avoir
un un avortement par aspiration
chirurgicale euh c'est vraiment une
discussion avec ces personnes-là et de
savoir dans leur situation déjà ce qui
est le plus adapté hein par rapport au
délai mais aussi euh le choix de la
personne ce qu' ce qu'elle va préférer
et euh et donc euh voilà on a fait donc
54000 rorientation vers des
professionnel je j'ai utilisé
professionnel de santé mais euh je
voudrais plutôt dire professionnel de
l'avortement parce que on parle pas que
des docteurs hein dans ce cas-là on peut
parler infirmier infirmière pharmacien
pharmacienne doula sage-femme et en les
femmes en tout cas les personnes
enceintes sont même expertes elles-mêm
de leur avortement dans dans
l'autogestion donc c'est vraiment le
spectre des professionnel de
l'avortement est assez
large donc nous on les recrute on les
filtre et on les forme le recrutement ça
se passe soit en direct avec notre
équipe de de partenariat mais aussi en
énorme collaboration avec avec les
autres ONG comme
DKT ou Mary stopes ou ippf voilà qui
mettent à dispos position aussi leur
liste de professionnels dans chaque pays
on travaille avec des organisations
féministes partout et on on met tous ses
contacts alors on a créé une base de
données
cryptée qui est seulement utilisée par C
CHUS parce que c'est quand même des
informations assez
sensible et on on les forme aussi donc
comme Nejma a parlé avec Descat on a
aussi créé des des formation en ligne
pour les professionnels de l'humanitaire
pour les pharmaciens en pharmaciennees
pour les étudiants en médecine aussi
parce que c'est quand même un un vrai
problème le le la prise en charge de
l'avortement est pas enseigné dans
beaucoup de d'écoles de médecine eu et
voilà le but c'est de renforcer les
capacités locales aussi parce que nous
on est une petite équipe donc on on
travaille avec les personnes sur le
terrain eu et on demande aussi bien sûr
à toutes les personnes qu'on a réorienté
de nous faire un retour sur leur sur
leur expérience et pour vérifier que les
personnes dans notre base de données
soient toujours pr choix soit toujours
au au niveau de qualité qu'on attend
pour une prise en charge de d'un
avortement et dans le troisème cas c'est
les pays où vraiment on a pas de
contact c'est très compliqué et là on on
va travailler par exemple avec woman on
Web ou womanen help women qui envoie les
pilules par la
poste je reviens rapidement juste sur
l'avortement médicamenteux parce que
neem en a parlé mais il y a deux
protocoles le combiipac qui est le
misoprostol MIF priston et le
misoprostol seulement c'est un protocole
un petit peu différent
mais le missoprostol est plus facile à
trouver parce que ce n'est pas que pour
l'avortement donc pour pour aussi les
ulcères par exemple donc ça peut être
troué sans ordonnance assez facilement
et donc dans les pays légalement
restreints en tout cas on travaille
beaucoup avec ce deuxième protocole pour
la petite
histoire comme Ann leg en parlit tout à
l'heure le laamif Freestone qui est un
peu sous menace aux États-Unis même si
ça fait un an et demi qu'on attend voilà
quand on a eu la nouvelle on a travaillé
avec des ONG américaines pour créer tous
les protocoles qui à la base sont pas
très utilisés aux États-Unis on utilise
surtout la MIF priston mais on a voilà
créé beaucoup de vidéos pour pour se
préparer au cas où la MIF priston soit
interdite en tout cas c'est bon à savoir
qu'il y a plusieurs options même dans
les questions de pénurie de
pilule et enfin un dernier point on en a
parlé aussi ce matin mais sur la
législation française en tout cas la
télémédecine sur l'IVG a été autorisée
pendant le covid elle est aujourd'hui à
9 semaines l'OMS recommande
l'autogestion
la démédicalisation de de de
l'avortement médicamenteux jusqu'à 12
semaines nous on travaille avec ces
protocoles là donc on est un tout petit
peu en retard en
France pour finir je je parle un petit
peu bah du du marketing digital en tout
cas de comment on parle d'avortement en
ligne nous en étant une plateforme
internationale digitale on peut parler
d'avortement qu'en ligne on va pas faire
un spot télé sur l'avortement et donc on
essaie de faire ça de façon un petit peu
attractive de un peu positive dire de
parler de ce sujet qui peut être
difficile dans dans certains contextes
et donc on a une équipe de designers
assez incroyable qui qui travaille voilà
à créer du contenu qui est un peu plus
fun et surtout déstigmatisant c'est
surtout le but donc ce soit autant un
peu médical mais que voilà un petit peu
plus fun sur tous les réseaux je vous ai
mis tous les réseaux sur lesquels on est
présent donc il faut vraiment adapter
aussi le contenu par pour le pour chaque
réseau mais aussi de comprendre dans
dans chaque région du monde comment on
recherche les informations et comment on
on peut en parler c'est pas c'est pas la
même façon de parler d'avortement en en
Afrique francophone que en Amérique
latine donc on essaie de s'adapter voilà
on a des choses un peu plus fun si vous
jouez à la Nintendo on a un jeu une
plateforme d'information sur un jeu
Nintendo et comme l'a dit Sandrine tout
à l'heure ce qui est aussi plus facile
pour nous c'est du fait qu'on soit
international et qu'on ne soit pas dans
un pays en particulier on on peut
vraiment parler d'avortement un peu plus
librement et permettre nous de
réorienter vers les professionnels de
santé dans chaque pays qui sont eux un
peu et qui ne peuvent pas parler
de de de ce qu'ils font alors
malheureusement je vais terminer sur
quelque chose d'un peu moins positif
mais parler en ligne d'avortement euh
c'est pas libre
euh on est sujet à la censure tout le
temps euh là je vous ai mis un exemple
de notre compte Youtube qui a été perdu
plusieurs fois la plus la dernière fois
c'était juste après le renversement de
Ry Wade euh et on on perd nos comptes
Facebook Instagram assez régulièrement
souvent à la suite de report de
signalement massif de groupes antichoix
des États-Unis ou du Brésil c'est ce
qu'on a identifié mais aussi des fois
c'est un petit peu au hasard ça va être
les les algorithmes Google qui vont
changer et on va se réveiller et le site
internet sera à la page numéro 10 euh ça
peut être des algorithmes qui sont au
hasard juste parce que parce que google
change tout le temps et qu'il faut être
très réactif mais aussi des fois elles
sont ciblées hein pour pour le sur le
droit des femmes la santé des femmes eu
donc il faut toujours être attentif à ça
avoir une vraie stratégie digitale comme
n'importe quel autre site internet et
aussi faire attention à la prolifération
des fausses informations on en a parlé
je tout à l'heure en parlit des
pregnancy crisis Center tout ce qui se
passe sur le terrain ça se passe en
ligne aussi les investissements massifs
des groupes antichoix sur les pubs
internet sur les faux sites Internet les
pregnancy crisis Center qui ont des
sites Internet qui sont très bien
financés et très bien
référencés voilà donc le le combat en
ligne il est le même que sur le terrain
et il faut rester vigilant on est en
train de créer une coalition avec
plusieurs organisations aussi pour
parler de de la censure de l'avortement
en ligne donc j'invite les sénateurs et
sénatrices qui sont intéressés à nous
rejoindre merci beaucoup mais merci à
vous de de ces témoignage et et en tout
cas de même si il y a des obstacles et
notamment ce que j'entends c'est aussi
sur la question de la censure qui
effectivement dont on avait pas parlé je
suis toujours frappé par le fait que on
peut pas arriver à faire de censure
auprès des serveurs sur des choses
essentielles où il y a de la haine de la
violence mais sur tout d'un coup sur les
choses qui enlèvent des droits là tout
d'un coup on arrive à faire de la
censure mais je ferme la parenthèse
est-ce que vous avez des
question à nos
intervenants
toi tu en avais une appar oui oui moi
j'avais justement une question qui qui
rejoignait le système d'information je
me posais la question de savoir s'il y
avait justement là vous avez parlé d'un
site qui qui qui fait une information
pour les femmes directes en particulier
d'aide en fait assez concrète aussi pour
pouvoir agir mais justement sur
l'information d'avoir un site
d'information européen ou même
internationale qui permettent d'avoir
une information fiable labélisée euh sur
sur la question d'avortement que ce soit
pour les professionnels de santé ou
d'avortement que ce soit pour les femmes
ou que ce soit aussi euh pour pour les
les organisations ou euh ou les élus de
tous les pays pour que on puisse avoir
des informations assez sûres parce que
face à la désinformation le problème à
chaque fois c'est d'avoir quelque chose
de labélisé et sûr même quand on le veut
c'est pas toujours évident à voir donc
je voulais savoir si il y avait quelque
chose là-dessus qui qui qui commence à
exister ou qui existait déjà ou si voilà
ah ben je vous invite à venir voir save
to choose vous pouvez venir voir save to
choose mais non il y a beaucoup de sites
internet mais comme je disais c'est
c'est compliqué en il y avait une
citation sur la la la slide qui était
que il y a 70 % de chance de plus d'une
information fausse d'être repartagée que
d'une information fiable donc ça déjà
c'est voilà les algorithmes qui aiment
partager des fausses informations euh
mais il y en a il y en a beaucoup mais
c'est vrai qu'elles sont aussi perdues
au milieu de fausses
informations ma question était surtout
sur la question de savoir s'il y avait
un pas que il existe des sites comme le
vôtre bien ça j'ai bien compris mais en
revanche s'il y en avait un
pardon la mise en place d'une
labellisation pour dire ça c'est juste
et ça c'est fa c'est c'est ça ça qui est
je je je trouve actuellement qui manque
dans le dans le circuit c'est qu'on peut
pas c'est difficile de s'y reconnaître
et que l'OMS par exemple puisse faire
quelque chose pour la bellliser ou enfin
voilà ou faire elle-même ou relayer ce
serait quelque chose d'intéressant je
vais vous relaisser la parole mais je
donne la parole d'abord à Laurence
rossinol qui a une question puis vous
répondraz qu'on peut et prè une table
ronde et poser une question
an juste j'ai pas j'ai peut-être été à
un moment absente vous n'avez pas parlé
de vos financements est-ce que vous avez
des sous euh et et d'où viennent-ils
dans ce que dans la mesure vous pouvez
nous répondre à cette question et est-ce
que vous êtes fait deslevés de fond
voilà je oui je peux commencer merci
oui on a des sous alors comme la table
ronde le disait précédemment il y a
quand même la la Global gag rule qui
empêche beaucoup de financement he pour
l'avortement mais oui il y a des gens
qui sont intéressés par financer la
ortement ça peut être des des agences
internationales de développement ou des
philanthropistes privé euh voilà des ou
des euh des entreprises privées aussi
mais je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
dur de trouver des financement que les
groupes antichoix ça c'est
sûr non peut-être sur le donc sur la
question des financements donc Médecin
du Monde est financé à 50 % par ces
donateurs privés donc on a cette chance
là d'indépendant tendance quelque part
d'une certaine manière de pouvoir mettre
nos actions bah là où nos donateurs nous
suivent donc ça c'est une première chose
euh et après on a quand même des
bailleurs institutionnels qui nous
suivent et on les remercie notamment le
gouvernement français mais pas que hein
le gouvernement canadien le gouvernement
allemand il a il y a plusieurs baayur
institutionnels qui nous permettent de
mettre en œuvre des des projets de
terrain et je vous mais c'est voilà
parfois toujours plus difficile et
effectivement avec l'évolution euh des
tendances politiques actuelles bah on
s'inquiète comme tout le monde et tu
peux tu évoquer le global gagroule mais
je voudrais insister sur un point c'est
aussi comment on renforce le financement
des acteurs locaux sur le terrain parce
que c'est très bien de nous financer
évidemment je veux pas vous dire le
contraire mais il a il y a la question
des financements de ces acteurs locaux
qui ont plus de difficultés euh à à
avoir accès à des financements
internationaux soit parce que c'est
difficile parce qu'ils sont méconnus et
cetera donc il y a eu effectivement une
initiative de du gouvernement français
en ce sens-là euh de depuis de 2 ans
pour que pour permettre l'accès au
financement euh euh féministes euh des
des acteurs locaux mais c'est
certainement des initiatives à à
renforcer euh par la par la suite et sur
la question de des sites il me semble si
je me trompe pas et je crois qu'on l'a
évoqué dans la table ronde précédente
que le gouvernement français a mis en
place un un site d'information alors
l'OMS a un site internet je il est
plutôt à destination des professionnels
euh que du grand public je pense qu'il
est pas très user friendly pour le pour
le grand public même nous professionnels
parfois on a du mal à s'y retrouver mais
oui c'est certainement des initiatives à
renforcer
oui très bien ben moi il me reste à vous
remercier tous parce que ces trois
tables rondes étaient franchement très
enrichissantes très
complémentaire et puis ça nous a permis
je pense de voir que le sujet était un
vrai sujet international et pas du tout
franco-français que les
attaques finalement comme les défenses
mais que les attaques étaient réellement
de niveau international et que les
réseaux en ces réseauxl sont aussi en
France et donc quand ce droit fragile
est menacé chez nos voisins il peut
effectivement l'être aussi chez nous et
et ne serait-ce que les différents
exemples européens que l'on a pu citer
qui ne sont pas forcément que la Hongrie
et la Pologne puisqu'on voit bien
l'Italie la Suède et peut-être demain
les Pays-Bas donc des pays qui à priori
normalement nous ressemblent et donc
voilà on n'est pas du tout à l'abri
d'une telle remise en cause il me semble
que il est nécessaire de de de de
s'associer puisque on le sait aussi ces
mouvements et là aussi on l'a dit ces
mouvements qui sont antivg sont aussi
antiontraception sont aussi anti
éducation à la vie sexuelle et affective
or là encore quand on travaille comme
j'ai pu le faire sur les violences
intrafamiliales
ou lorsqu'on a entendu dans notre
délégation le juge Édouard Duran on sait
bien que l'éducation à la vie affective
et sexuelle qui évidemment est adapté en
fonction des âges et que non on ne va
pas apprendre la masturbation aux
enfants de maternel par contre leur
apprendre que leur corps et leur corps
leur appartient leur apprendre ce que ce
qui ce qui ce qui se fait ou pas et que
parfois ce qui peut se faire à la maison
et bien non ils n'ont pas à le subir et
bien c'est par ça que ça peut passer et
donc c'est
effectivement contre les femmes et aussi
du coup contre les enfants que ces ces
mouvements euh euh lutte en réalité et
donc euh c'est et par ailleurs sur le
sujet très clairement euh de
l'avortement c'est un vrai sujet de
santé publique on l'a dit des femmes en
meurent l'important c'est de sécuriser
euh l'accès et donc euh nous devons
évidemment nous interroger sur la loi
mais aussi sur la pratique et euh de la
loi et sur les accès et ça on le sait
euh aussi en France c'est un c'est un
sujet la délégation en droit les femmes
continuera ce travail et donc merci
vraiment à tous et et à toutes à nos
intervenant bien entendu pour cette
matinée très enrichissante et aux
sénateurs et sénatrices qui sont venu et
celles qui sont restés jusqu'au bout
mais là encore je vous demande vraiment
de nous excuser parce que il y avait des
des il y a en même temps il y a séance
en même temps de tout ce que je vous ai
dit du Salon des mères et et des
différentes auditions donc c'était un
peu compliqué mais merci beaucoup parce
que de toute façon ce sera c'est ça a
étit en direct donc nous avons du des
gens qui nous ont regardé en direct
c'est été enregistré et donc cette table
ronde n'a pas fini son
chemin merci merci
[Applaudissements]
merci